so you
[Music]
can perfect
[Music]
song is going to get me every [ __ ]
time man
let's [ __ ] go let's go hi
how you guys doing
how's it going welcome the [ __ ] back
we're cussing early it's okay let's go
let's [ __ ] go season one [ __ ] done
welcome back to the very first episode
of season two this is the dopes usual
podcast we're here to talk about life
drugs accomplishments problems and
everything in between i [ __ ] got it
let's go i [ __ ] season two short and
strong
that [ __ ] is glowing behind you oh yeah
you like the new set you [ __ ]
like the new set this [ __ ] is glowing
[Applause]
i painted it myself
nah i'm just glad i didn't i [ __ ]
suck dick at art guys the new set behind
us is looking [ __ ] bomb believe it or
not it's spray paint shout out to zoe
one damon yeah
guys we were looking for an artist for a
couple weeks
found a couple artists
astronomically expensive is that what
you would say expensive as [ __ ]
um
so we got a quote from damon and uh
his quote was a little high for us
because
if you know who we're talking about he's
a [ __ ] badass
marty showed me the hermes building he
did and i was automatically like that's
the guy we need
that's that was spray paint that's the
[ __ ] because marty said what if
we hit it with spray paint differently
no no no no no that was he said he
suggested that he said it before we
continue yeah marty has a background
yeah anybody notice that marty's part of
the [ __ ] show now yeah a little bit
more cohesive yes we painted the entire
room everything's done our little
backdrop curtain thing going on
our seats behind us we're about to get
some neon actual neon lights put up guys
sorry continue he said
yeah he suggested that because he's not
just a spray paint artist he just he was
like i watched a couple of your episodes
and just the vibe of your show you
should really use spray paint it just
makes well that's ready stays like you
have like it's more like more street
wear [ __ ] or more
explicitness more street [ __ ] i think
spray paint would be a better vibe
that's exactly what he said you're right
i was like you're completely correct yes
so he came in here
crushed it look around this [ __ ] is not
neon
he crushed it okay he [ __ ] murdered
it so shout out to him i'm sure marty
threw up his instagram on this uh
overlays and stuff so thank you for
coming through the day after he painted
it we cut holes in the [ __ ] art to
insulate the walls
we planned them sometimes so we had to
have him come back so shout out to you
for coming back and fixing the little
holes thank you it looks great i am 100
astonished guys i'm wearing a sweater
all right it's three in the afternoon
because there's a brand new ac unit in
here behind this wall
is a door and a window that we
accidentally covered up with the other
set last year so now we just said [ __ ]
it close both sides up so this is a fake
wall behind me and the other set is
exactly where we used to sit for season
one
season one eight million views 36
episodes
hella homies that was season one for me
[ __ ] bomb
super excited 36 episodes and every one
of them hit i was super happy every
[ __ ] one i was not mad at any of them
going you know what next time i'm gonna
try not to do no
i'm sorry for me rambling but that's
part of the show
yeah that is the show that's the dart
yeah that's part of the [ __ ] show so
guys thank you for sticking through it i
don't know how many hours probably 60
hours worth of podcast yeah some were
three hours four hours long and
hopefully now no more planes trains and
[ __ ] crickets planes trains crickets
now we just got [ __ ]
dead
yep
hd studio quality who knows we're about
to we'll find out though yeah we're
about to sound proof the roof yeah all
right we're about to soundproof the
[ __ ] roof of a building soundproof
his entire wall covered it up put bars
all the insulation had uh the man that
gets paid mushrooms come over here give
us a consultation on sound and he loved
the mushrooms so that's [ __ ] awesome
quick update marty has now taken 2.5
grams of mushrooms and has not hit him
yeah i don't know what's his what's up
with his brain i don't understand but
you should enter some competitions i
don't know man i feel like i'm [ __ ]
doing something wrong but at the same
time i was just i took like you know
a magical fairy dropped off these little
micro dose [ __ ] uh capsules on me so
i was like yeah i mean yeah so it's okay
yeah the the magical yola man yeah
so i was like i popped one waiting for
it okay i popped the other one waiting
for i was kind of dipping my toe for the
first like two days like waiting for it
to work wait you didn't take them all
the same time well i did eventually oh i
kind of worked up to it though like then
the next day i was like all right let me
take two and then i took like the third
one like a little bit after just kind of
waiting for it
and then i think maybe two days ago i
was like [ __ ] it just four of them
i don't understand when you told me that
i was putting up that piece of material
because i remember looking back what the
[ __ ] did you say uh-huh so i'm sure i'm
i'm sure i'm going to try those little
chocolates
yeah your brain is natural
2.5 has got to get got me like this
like i'm like i'm on strings that's how
i feel off 2.5
so um
yeah we'll see though we'll keep you
guys [ __ ] keep you posted uh i'll
we'll know when there's a clip of marty
on the ground going what is [ __ ]
happening to me that's we'll know that
much
my daughter live streaming
i'm excited i'm excited um
so yeah that's what's been going on new
set is here
new set episode one i'm very excited
this season guys
i'm trying to switch it up a little bit
all right i'm trying to switch it up a
little bit not so ranted long
endless conversation that is in my brain
you imagine trying to sleep with all
this in my head
not fun yeah you know what shows think
about last night then i was like oh my
leg hurts and then i woke up today
so that's what i was doing last night
guys i'm gonna get right into this okay
um a new segment okay
anytime i want to talk about news or
current events
this is the new segment it's been called
what's poppin because
i don't think
hey what's in the news that's good is a
good topic it's not a good title what's
poppin that is the new title new segment
marty do your magic of editing what's
poppin
[Music]
there we go hopefully hopefully there's
an overlay when this comes out and
that'd be sick
are you ready marty i don't know if you
saw this but i'm gonna talk to you guys
i'm gonna talk to you and you for
everyone out there right now with the
bond between your knees holding it and
you're packing a bowl
thank you for being here shout out to
you shout out to everyone in the
bathroom of their work like this
trying to watch the show shout out to
everybody in school with the phone below
their [ __ ] leg
thank you for doing that i'm not
encouraging you guys to [ __ ] off your
your priorities
if you're dedicated enough that you're
at something and you're doing that
[ __ ] thank you that's all i'm saying
if you're in the car put the phone down
and just listen you can always watch it
later but you can't get your [ __ ]
life back okay please be safe be safe
driving
let's get into season one i'm
high we're done with season one let's
get into season two and uh on that note
how much time are we in i was just gonna
say 8 40.
we could do a little for the uh
that could be our 10-minute nice guy
clock yeah i like notifications is it 10
minutes yeah it's exactly 10 minutes
right now
that'd be funny don't tell the guests
thank you rosie for rolling my joints
don't tell the guest um i talked to
rosie guys i know you guys want rosie on
the show let me address this now i know
you want rosie on the show you guys ask
a lot she hates talking on camera she
doesn't [ __ ] like it but i told her
what about just popping in for a minute
and telling a story real quick because
you guys asked so much and i'm not gonna
go i need you on the show
get your [ __ ] ass over no nothing
like joe jackson on her yeah i'm not
gonna do that okay i'm not to hold her
by the back of her neck like talk
i just don't want to force her to do
anything i won't do but she said she
might be down so maybe season two rosie
will be sitting next to me
we'll see
every time
real quick before i go ahead and ash on
this [ __ ] can we just show this
thing i can't remember the company dude
i have it on the package but they just
sent it out of nowhere
very cool tray shout out to you guys
thank you thank you for that that's
[ __ ] awesome i really like it hell
yeah um
are you wait where's your computer
it's off
you'll need it no
no it's basically dead it's all right
yeah it's just we're good oh all right i
like the new computer look right here
yeah it's clean this is cool i like this
okay guys
what's popping segment i don't think if
marty's seen this yet because he's
responsible you know he doesn't just
scroll the internet and he has kids
experimenting with [ __ ] mushrooms
yeah he's over there experimenting with
mushrooms and editing so
what's popping ready my very first thing
i need you guys to go [ __ ] look at
this i need you to watch this marty
please put this on an overlay pop-up
have you seen
something costa this [ __ ] guy
yesterday or two days ago posted a clip
of himself he's an actor already i'm
gonna look at the camera [ __ ] sorry this
is so nice though we're like no i'm
looking straight at you this is great
this [ __ ] did like a little
segment scene on his own youtube
but do you need an ashtray sir is that a
water bottle you're about to use for an
answer bro no i do not need an ashtray
oh that's right
i'm taking the label off this goddamn
water bottle that's what's going on yeah
sorry continue
this man on his youtube impersonated
robin williams and he did uh a piece
basically robin williams in his dress
dressing room getting ready to be on
morgan mindy you know like an actor
pre-gaming oh hello hello doing all this
thing
guys it starts and it doesn't show robin
williams i thought it was [ __ ] robin
williams i am very good with
voices recognized you guys know i
remember almost everything
i cannot tell the difference between
this man and robert williams i can't do
it you couldn't pay me to stop different
it's [ __ ] did you see it i was i was
standing up sitting over here just
looking at it on your phone not really
being able to see but it never dawned on
me it wasn't him i couldn't [ __ ]
believe and yes people could do voices
that's great
but the mannerisms
the way he's moving his wrists
everything
i love robin williams man i love hook i
love mrs doubtfire i love you every i
love what dreams may come world
according to garp you guys know all of
these movies i [ __ ] love robin
williams death
and this man crushed it so severe even
when he sat down into the slow like
robin williams sad face is always like
is he about to smile oh he's crying no
robin williams crying is the saddest
thing on earth to watch it seem like
this dude trained his whole life for
this for just this role right
so we'll pop it up on the screen i need
you guys to go watch this i know it's a
little small clip but it's [ __ ]
incredible i have never been more
astonished besides jay pharaoh you ever
seen jay pharaoh
his impersonations mm-hmm
yeah
yeah he even
even when he does eddie murphy his
[ __ ] face changes to eddie murphy and
it blew my mind yeah there's a different
level to impersonation when you start to
look to look like the person yeah like
even the facial express like you have to
tuck these muscles just to do that while
you're remembering to do that yeah is a
talent yeah so go check it out robin
williams actor skit i watched i don't
know what it's called i'm sorry but
we'll pop it up on the internet we'll
pop it up on the overlay check it out
first segment of what's popping let's
get going all right i need you guys to
go watch that robin williams still
popping out here still still you're
always going to be the genie to me even
though will smith did an all right job
he didn't bug me did he he didn't know i
didn't hear a [ __ ] about them he didn't
it was a great movie i really liked the
aladdin actual uh live action
it did make me go you guys [ __ ]
ruined it and when you make me feel that
way
you [ __ ] up yeah you take that [ __ ]
you [ __ ] up yeah you know
cause i'm i'm a kid i was a kid when
that came out you can't [ __ ] up a child
a person's childhood and it's just done
yeah it's like remaking the ponies yeah
okay
don't [ __ ] touch it space drum
just stick to dunkin
stick to dunk it oh
you [ __ ] jumped through the
[ __ ] out of here you scared me you
scared me and then i thought wait
how the [ __ ] did that sound come through
these sound insulated walls
yeah thanks it's a military ship jerk
ready
guys segment two i mean not segment two
part two of what's popping my next thing
in the news next current event next
topic you ready
i was just talking [ __ ] to og about the
raiders i mean i was just talking [ __ ]
the raiders are my second favorite team
i just like to talk [ __ ] okay it's funny
to me to make fun of raider fans
because they're always going to talk
shitty if i make fun of you anyway it
doesn't matter raider fans raiders are
good
so in the news
john gruden chucky john gruden the
raiders coach we all grew up with john
gruden we all know if you're over 35 to
40 you grew up probably with john madden
or something
would you rather john gruden all right
chucky not john madden
this [ __ ] if you guys don't know
what's going on
the raiders have the first openly gay
football player right he's the first
openly gay athlete in the nfl
props to him super [ __ ] cool
you're a brave [ __ ] that's
badass and it being gay doesn't mean you
can't crack a [ __ ] it doesn't
mean you're not gonna [ __ ] catch over
me so it's like
really showing people like bro he's gay
who
gives a [ __ ]
he's not [ __ ] up your money and if he
is that means he's better than you and
you shouldn't be here anyway
that's how i feel about the whole gay
guy thing who gives a [ __ ] is it a
highly publicized thing in football or
not so there's a lot of gay players but
not a lot of people wanna it's because
there's a lot of ignorant people in
america still and they were like
may not buy that jersey anymore they may
not support that team maybe they might
not go to i think it would be a good
look for the the team in this i mean
like people are ignorant bro people are
ignorant people are very homophobic
still but
the way i see it it's like you're not
trying to [ __ ] rape me right that i
don't give a [ __ ] who you have sex with
guy yeah
do you ask the guy with the girl from
like well who else do you bang i have a
problem with you who you have sex with
it doesn't matter sorry i have to get
off of this whole [ __ ] grant yeah so
they have the first openly gay football
player right on the raiders they just
moved to vegas
john gruden is the coach the head coach
in 2011 when he wasn't even the raiders
coach anymore because he used to be the
raiders coach was a kid quit for a long
time came back recently
2011 he's worth espn wasn't even a coach
he said something
uh like something homophobic about the
rams
about the rams
and og's telling him he's like yeah he
called him queers or something and i go
wait wait
but was it funny or was he being a piece
of [ __ ]
yeah you know i mean like there's a fine
line of like yo
that was pretty [ __ ] funny
but also you're a dick
and there's and there's like
yo do you do you seriously not like gay
fools are you [ __ ] kidding me are you
do you have a problem get the [ __ ] out
of here there's a fine line me i know
people probably get offended that i said
was it fun i don't give a [ __ ] get
offended football coaches aren't known
for being real [ __ ] funny guys yeah
they're not known for being real [ __ ]
hilarious all right but um
comedies to me is comedy i don't care if
you're making fun of mexican people i'm
mexican you're making fun of fat guys
i'm fat i don't give a [ __ ] anybody can
get it anybody can [ __ ] get exactly
any nobody safe you make it dunked on
but if it's out of just trying to make
you laugh or make it like damn that was
kind of [ __ ] up that was pretty funny
that's the [ __ ] i like all right so
that's the first thing i asked joji was
it funny because i don't think it was
funny but i think he was just being a
dick
[ __ ] him then
then they more emails came out about him
making racist jokes or not jokes these
aren't jokes he's making he's saying
racist and homophobic [ __ ] i get it
people make mistakes
he was showing his true colors in an
email which is fine
ah raiders didn't hire him for his
[ __ ] ethics
i get it you know what i'm saying
they're not like yo how do you would you
stance on abortion
[ __ ] you can't run in [ __ ] zone
that's not how it works but i also would
not hire a piece of [ __ ] so i understand
where you guys are probably in the
comments what do you mean
if it's funny to me it's funny if you're
a piece of [ __ ] i ain't gonna [ __ ] with
you it's about your intention it's about
your intentions what were you trying to
hurt someone's feeling are you trying to
be a piece of [ __ ] and do you really
believe that
there's a difference anyway this
[ __ ] didn't take any chances
john gruden straight up resigned
the [ __ ] guy just quit the team
just did you know what
[ __ ] you guys i'm going home that's
exactly what happened because he's got
to go into that locker room on monday
with a gay player after the world knows
he made super homophobic remarks
racist [ __ ] which i'm assuming is black
or mexican
and the raiders are
they're not too many white dudes on this
team but he's just saying racist white
[ __ ] against all of them yo how funny
would that be if he was just racist
against white people that's kind of
funny too
it's just look it i know he's being
saying racist [ __ ] i didn't see what he
said
was it a joke was it funny makes a big
difference
to me funny racist [ __ ] is off the cuff
funny race shit's funny it's not usually
found in emails and i've never been
no no
but i mean dave chappelle says funny
racist [ __ ] every day yeah so don't be
[ __ ] splitting hairs here
[ __ ] oh he's not a comedian
all right
so
human comedians can be funny i mean
other people can be funny
if your intentions are bad
you're [ __ ]
because a lot of people out here are
finally waking up and going no no i
don't [ __ ] with you for being a racist
it used to be oh well you know you're my
boss well now now [ __ ] just
quit which i love i [ __ ] with this
there's an intolerance for intolerance
title title
um
but yeah so john gruden your raiders
guys out there all your raider fans out
there i'm sorry but your coach is gone
he's a good ass [ __ ] coach
uh [ __ ] good riddance bro who gives a
[ __ ] you saw his last game huh
he got [ __ ] raped but i'm saying was
that the game you were at no no no he
played the emails came out friday he
played he was a coach till sunday game
he got wiped
on sunday so maybe with his players
maybe his players like you know what
[ __ ] you
because you gotta remember that's your
coach that's your homie that's like your
[ __ ] boss you're very tight with him
and then you like
is this how you feel about people
well how do you feel about me
that's how i would feel like yo you're
racist out there what the [ __ ] you
saying about me when i'm not totally
yeah so he thought it better just to
leave
so what's popping
john gruden he's [ __ ] out raiders you
need a new coach
preferably not someone too ignorant all
right preferably someone that's just
there for the game
let's go
guys next segment of what's popping i
almost said shmegma oh [ __ ] that's
shmagma
word no shmegma is the dirty [ __ ] in
people's dick oh that's what schmegma is
i learned that i'm sad i still don't
know what you're referring to but it
sounds don't wash their body and there's
like a [ __ ] film of like dirt fungus
and the layer of your dick is called
it's so specific
it has its own word it must be happening
unless you're a bad teacher miss adams
and i said that wrong then i'm just
playing with you
which is one of the only things i
learned in your class okay
[ __ ] out of here because i thought it
was funny there's a word for something
like that
and i always used to tell people you got
some shmegmo on your lips what
yes
i was [ __ ] 18 saying this stupid [ __ ]
like a dumbass next next uh part of
what's poppin
makes perfect sense dave chappelle's
cancelled question mark dot dot dot
[ __ ] okay so let's get into this i
didn't even put these back to back on
purpose
what does it have to do with schmegma
i don't know about this i heard about
john gruden
okay oh okay
no that's not what i'm saying okay you
ready
guys dave chappelle i haven't seen it i
haven't seen it guys i'm only going
based off of
the [ __ ] i've read
i haven't seen the special yet but
apparently
dave chappelle's going hard on the trans
community
apparently he's going extra hard on them
i saw his last special where he did the
bi trans straight gay lesbian joke
by far one of the smartest well thought
out jokes i've ever seen
it was very very [ __ ] funny did you
see it
i saw the special a while ago i don't
know that's like two years ago yeah when
he released two specials once right yeah
that's the one where he's talking about
the trans community and he's all there's
they're mad at me like that's how he's
starting these [ __ ] they're mad
yeah which look it
if you have an actual problem with trans
people you probably did no but i'm sure
he just he just loves to make fun of
people because he's a [ __ ] comedian
and why i'm talking about it right now
it's funny it's funny i can you can make
fun of horrible things and still make it
funny i've heard auschwitz jokes
i have heard yeah there's no way to be a
comedian not to offend some group yeah
some group's gonna be offended hey knock
knock who's there i'm offended i don't
even have a door
shut the [ __ ] up bro get out of here you
can't please everybody so you might as
well go after the audience that [ __ ]
with you and the audience that [ __ ]
with you are people that enjoy comedy
dave chappelle so good job so people are
trying to cancel dave japel right now
you cannot cancel somebody that doesn't
give a [ __ ] and i've said it many many
times you can't cancel somebody that
does not give a [ __ ] about the
cancellation
if deschappelle is going to cancel you
would have did in 2003
okay
we talked about this many times
you stabbed my dad that skit
alone
clayton bixby
black right the black kkk
member should have got it
there's a lot of things that should be
we were smarter back then though i feel
like people weren't insensitive you
weren't sensitive and now apparently his
new special came out people trying to
cancel it all i'm seeing is comedians
just like applauding the [ __ ] so david
alan grier said it's freed all the black
i freed all the comedy slaves
that bit freed comedy slaves is what he
said and david alan greer and i saw i'm
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry damon williams okay david allen
grier damon williams said this and he's
a hardcore [ __ ]
who was telling us what comedian was
josh wolfe
he was telling us that uh damon williams
like when he gets on stage sometimes
people just leave because he goes so
[ __ ] hard on the crowd oh yeah that's
right like he doesn't talk [ __ ] the
whole [ __ ] set
just like deciphering nutty professor
yeah that's just what i think yeah yeah
yeah reggie
who's sucking who's teddies up in hell
yo when he's
reggie
when [ __ ] did you fail
when he pulls his hat off and everybody
left shitlock your face yeah oh my god
sorry to get off topic dave chappelle is
hysterical you can't cancel the funniest
man alive it's not gonna happen
all right even if he says horrible [ __ ]
unless he means this [ __ ] which i think
he don't it's different from like you
want to cancel tony henchcliffe for his
[ __ ] rant i feel like that was much
more cancelable barty i wasn't very
aware tony hitchcliff
rosie goes to kill tony with her friend
sammy a lot where they do like the open
mic and stuff they used to rip
yeah used to yeah and uh
wait that show's gone
uh no they do it they do it in uh texas
now oh [ __ ] yeah
the whole comedy store era is no don
okay so
i never seen tony hendricks stand up
never seen it
he kind of looks like the kid from big
mouth
there's a show called big mouth and he
kind of looks identical to the kid from
he reminds me of norman bates
psycho just how he looks right yeah i'm
going to talk about it i never seen this
stuff but
you showed me the
thing he got canceled for during asian
hate
anti-asian hate month
yeah the [ __ ] he said seemed like he was
coming from a place of [ __ ] hatred
i understand if he was trying to be
funny that's great
just don't be i mean he just came off
bad he came off very like
yeah there's
there's nothing funny about those like
wolf oh yeah i want to leave yeah if you
make other people go oh
and it's also like uh bro it's not that
we're not understanding this [ __ ] wasn't
really meant to be funny it's not uh it
just wasn't really it's not part of your
bit like he thought it was good yeah his
dad just died his wife cheated on him
hey give him a hand like yeah
yeah no well none of that was meant to
be funny you're just the [ __ ] forever
you can just be a [ __ ] [ __ ] too
you're allowed to just be you're not uh
you know untouchable from that because
you're a comedian yeah
exactly real quick
what time we at
28. that's not bad
i think we actually might do an hour and
a half this time season one we're
starting struggles yeah we're starting
strong going an hour and a half today
so that's going to conclude this segment
of what's popping okay that is what's
popping
news segment current events whatever you
want to call it what else is popping is
i'm going to [ __ ] monday night
football so uh
that would be helpful on a quicker yeah
is flying to tennessee to watch the
bills smash on the titans
not a game he's gonna go watch the
buffalo bills beat the [ __ ] out the time
i'm not used to being cocky and
confident the bills are are looking
[ __ ] ridiculous they
molested the chief's last one i [ __ ]
love that because that was personal that
they knocked us out last year that was
statutory rape yeah they've ruined them
the first couple games we beat the [ __ ]
out of the except for when we gave the
game and the steelers we were beating
the [ __ ] out of the team but we were
still playing horrible we weren't
looking good but i feel like these past
two games we're looking good and winning
also yeah i just want to say how much i
love looking your direction and it's
nice behind you oh i was going to say
that we actually have like straight
yeah
it was bothering me how much og had to
keep leaning back and talking backwards
yeah like no now we can all just it's
like we're on the same [ __ ] set
better now oh geez and he started
watching the episode
he said i got up to where you said
what about the edibles that made your
friend's dad die
he's like oh man i just turned it off
man i can't watch it no more
i can see that moment again get getting
up things flying shutting the tv off
these are full
um
marty's going to see monday night
[ __ ] football flying all the
way to tennessee so if you see marty in
tennessee which you probably won't
recognize because it's tennessee and
it's full of dudes that look just like
marty but if you see marty
high five his ass all right
oh yeah wait
you're going to tennessee the second
that josh wolfe is flying here isn't
that weird
how weird is that josh you're gonna be
here the day you leave it's so weird i
know i realize that hey are we gonna be
able to film with him
yeah i mean you guys are gonna have to
figure it out
[Laughter]
he's supposed to feel so much yeah he
knows how to do his high live [ __ ] or
whatever he can
you guys have to [ __ ] figure it out
[Laughter]
you dick
mario's going to want you been to mine
in that football no yeah i went to my
first monday night well last week i went
by bill's fan this is a [ __ ] first
i'm excited for you i've never been to
another team stadium football stadium
i've never been to the packers stadium
so i've only been to other teams
that's what you'll be doing this weekend
this weekend rosie
tomorrow my mom my sister the one from
all the death story times almost trying
to kill me my aunt pepper my aunt
loretta they're all coming down to la
because rosie found the wedding dress
that she likes and they're gonna go
check it out together
do their thing do you know what type of
venue you guys want to do
chuck e cheese
i wouldn't even be mad at that [ __ ]
as long as they brought the guys out to
uh-huh they don't do that anymore really
it's so that's why
but i want them to do the schmurder
dance thing that my uncle john used to
do all the time but
they rebranded with that weak ass logo
and chucky none of them they used to be
dancing on the stage when i was a kid
yeah they used to be tweaking and now
they're not doing [ __ ] then they had
robots that was weird the robot was not
supposed to move the robot
yeah
yeah i was like
that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up as a kid so i was
staring like i know it's watching me but
i can't [ __ ] prove that it's watching
me so i'm gonna stare at it just like
you were your kid right now leave in the
comments as a kid did you ever just
stare i mean real bad after toy story
came out but did you ever start your
toys like i know you move [ __ ]
and i know you look at me when i'm
asleep
i know my action figures are moving in
this in the night
just [ __ ] chill with me
just do it like what i could see because
you could communicate [ __ ] it
must beat my sister's ass
scare her like sid
in toy story yes
probably get no comments because nobody
else thinks
nobody else is going to comment oh real
quick do me a favor right now if you are
on youtube watching right now
check if you are subscribed to this
channel and check if your notifications
are on for this channel youtube is to
keep taking it off of people's channel
i've had hundreds and hundreds of
messages saying hey i should be to
subscribe since episode one and now i'm
not and no notifications
i don't know if it's a glitch i don't
know if youtube's like yeah let's slow
the traffic down on these [ __ ]
i don't know what's going on but we're
also not getting recommended anymore
we're not getting on any recommended
pages
it's all right thank you guys for being
here still but just real quick while
we're in this just check and if you're
not subscribed subscribe please if you
remember leave a like on this video just
a little thumbs up it really [ __ ]
helps
all right here we go
mario's going to monday night football
my whole family will be here this
weekend
let's move on to one more thing one more
thing that we'll probably never talk
about again
i don't know what you're gonna say a few
episodes ago we talked about the whole
seth rogen [ __ ] right the whole
we said our piece maybe a lot of you
don't agree maybe think we're reaching
i know what i feel inside we talked
about it we said what we needed to say
makes sense to me
so
you guys are dicks
our fans are slightly dicks now to talk
about you guys
that's for the fact let me bring up what
happened the seth rogen situation the
conclusion
you guys are dicks the last time we
talked about this on the show
was three weeks ago
all right we talked about how
we talked to real quick recap we talked
to seth rogers management to get him on
this show this exact show we asked him
you should come on the show i think it'd
be good
they said let's check out your [ __ ]
we'll get back to you they said yeah we
checked everything out it looks great we
love it we love the other youtube it's
great but when he has time
boom all real quick
uh four months later they never come on
the show then they start their own
podcast called story time that's the
font
the
the template was orange it was kind of
weird like we only use orange it's
called story time it used to be called
story time with yola
just stacked up right like oh damn did
his management just look at our [ __ ] and
go hey let's use this formula right here
we talked about this before he probably
wasn't him
here's the update you guys are dicks
like i said
seth rogen last week posted hey my very
first podcast episode scout it's called
story time check it out i think it's
original that's what he wrote
that is like that's what he wrote yeah
that's weird
you guys took it upon yourselves to [ __ ]
on it it's like he was asking for you
guys [ __ ] on it i never asked you to do
that
i mean it's in the other podcast episode
i would never ask you guys to be mean to
seth rogen i love that guy
if there was a thousand comments on his
post 90 i mean 940 of them
were you guys being dicks
but you're saying what you think
you guys a lot of you guys are being
brutally honest i shouldn't say dicks a
lot of you guys are being brutally
honest what you feel so 940 out of a
thousand comments were like yo you're
just straight stealing story time you
guys are stealing your thief blah blah
blah blah blah i never asked for that
but also thank you guys for having my
back that's very cool of you
it's not fun to go up against the
[ __ ] it's not fun to go up against
the biggest [ __ ] pothead in the world
ready
and like i said we're not going up
against anything we just think maybe his
management yeah influence piping for
yourself that's all it was we're like yo
by the way we've been doing that for a
year just won't let you guys know that's
all we were saying
the next morning seth rogen dm's me
i did not expect that [ __ ] at all
so there's hell of comments of people
just talking [ __ ] like yo look not even
tagging me saying yola [ __ ] question
mark what the [ __ ]
like yeah uh double zl's already on
season three this is pretty unoriginal
like just people talking [ __ ] and i
never asked for that so you guys took it
upon yourself so i'll i do appreciate
you guys have my [ __ ] back
next morning after that post seth rogen
dms me personally which i went my dance
with is this for real
this fool really dm'ing me
and yeah seth rogen dm me all right he
dme
and was like yo i've heard you know
you're telling people i stole your stuff
but i never saw your stuff until
yesterday when people kept tagging me
like i'd really like to talk to you and
get to the bottom of this
and i thought i was actually in this
other room when they were painting where
we're doing the rest of this the set and
i was like
i'm going to respond to this guy because
he came at me polite as [ __ ] so i talked
to him like first i always want to say
i did not say you're stealing my [ __ ] if
you want to check out this [ __ ] link
i said i don't think it's you i think
maybe your management ha or your
production team looked at our stuff
after we talked to him and said hey
here's a suggestion i even wrote i even
dm'd him i said bro i said it's [ __ ]
seth rogen why would he know who i am
it's seth rogen i text that to seth
rogen which i thought was really funny
as i'm texting it like it's [ __ ] seth
rogen why would he know
anyway i thought it was really funny as
i'm texting seth rogen this [ __ ]
and we're talking for like 20 minutes
and i'm like going back and forth like
dude
letting you know like i'm just talking
how i think
i
feel after and he's like what do you
mean you talk to my production team
like dude i talk to somebody on your
production team your management team
that's who i talked to that's who i got
a hold of
he goes who what's his name who did this
blah blah so he goes bro i did not i've
never seen your [ __ ] and i'm talking to
him like dude
that's what i thought like why would you
just look at some kid online and go
stealing it and he goes i wouldn't do
that and i go i know
and in my head i'm like i'm such a fan
of this man since freaks and geeks i was
[ __ ] 12 years old
that i'm like dude and i even put dude
i've been watching since freaks and
geeks i love your ass i would never come
at you sideways i just [ __ ] said what
i had to say
he goes dude can you do me a favor and
like make a post telling people that i
didn't just steal your [ __ ]
and i went
in my head i went
hey man why don't you just make that
post
and then i thought you know what i'll
make the post you can't make me polite
you can't so i talk
you guys got to remember
i'm just a [ __ ] youtuber youtube guy
we're doing podcasts we're going hi
that guy's on [ __ ] some of our
favorite movies of all time i quote them
story times you guys know how many times
i've quoted
seth rogen's [ __ ] movie so to have
him dm at me like yo can you please make
a post
that just really shows how strong you
guys are
holy [ __ ] you guys talked so much [ __ ]
this guy [ __ ] asked me politely can
you please make a post telling everybody
what we talked about
so shout out to you guys for having my
[ __ ] back because i it's not like i
said yo this guy didn't pay me like on
notorious we talked about it we didn't
say go notorious and go tell them that
they're pieces of [ __ ] and go find
peter's house and egg no we didn't do
any of that [ __ ] because we're not gonna
activate our fans to be jerks
we're gonna let you know what's going on
we're just letting you guys know what's
going on so in conclusion uh
i talked to him and toward the end of
the conversation i don't think it was
really seth rogen i think it was his
management
because i started getting a little
frantic
i'm sorry i'm just going to talk about
it i don't give a [ __ ] it started
talking like
is this seth rogen because why is he
like
asking me so many times to please post
he didn't say please post please take it
down he's like can you please please
tell everybody please tell him i didn't
steal my damn fool okay calm down i'll
do it damn i don't think it was seth
rogen
because after that they post they posted
on seth rogen's page they posted a
picture that he's eating a hamburger and
it was a mexican dude's hand
it's not a brown that's a brown hand i
watched it's pretty safe to assume i
feel like first yeah i don't think if
you don't see them on their story or
live stream i don't look at his i don't
know about his page but i don't think it
was him i don't think it was him because
this morning the story
it's probably the dude that made the
[ __ ] story part of the dude that made
it it was like yo i can't have seth
actually see this [ __ ] let me hit this
kid up right now and [ __ ] nip this
[ __ ]
is what i'm i'm i'm not saying it's true
guys so don't [ __ ] twist my words i'm
just saying i may be
not done
so seth rogen also dm my friend super
smack bros jay and dm's marty's friend
anybody that was talking [ __ ] on that
post he dm'd
it's a lot it's a lot of people to dm
but he also dm the podcast and it was a
copy paste of what he dm'd me so i'm
like wait
was that even really seth rogen
or was it his management team
because they sex jay super smack bros
like yo this guy's over here being a
liar he's lying and telling everybody
this stuff don't believe him
i was like what the [ __ ] he came at you
like that
are you guys really set like
so this is my conclusion i thought i was
talking to seth rogen super polite i
squashed it because he told me i didn't
steal it so i'm like that's all i needed
to hear from you bro that's all i needed
and i posted it you saw my post saying
hey just talk seth rogen
i think it's management team because he
says he has no [ __ ] idea who we are
just like we said on the last episode
so
but when you text my homie jay that [ __ ]
i'm like damn he came at you way
different bro what the [ __ ] this guy's a
liar
i read the dm i go what the [ __ ]
weird
so i don't know what to think i honestly
don't know what to think but i know seth
rogen posted episode two and people are
still going hard on him
i never asked for you guys to talk [ __ ]
he did change that color today
they did change the orange off though
they did change the orange color
so thank you guys for having my back
yeah in conclusion i think i talked to
seth rogen at least it was his account
super nice dude got to the bottom of it
but
kinda yeah kinda he really i mean until
i meet seth rogen in person go yo what's
up with the story time [ __ ]
i don't really know what to say but then
again i don't give a [ __ ] we said what
we had to say guys i will never bring
this [ __ ] up again i promise it's never
going to be brought up again because i
don't care enough to dwell on this [ __ ]
i only put it in here because it's done
because people were talking so much [ __ ]
from that last episode
you know what how about i just talk
about in this first episode talk about
yo can you guys please stop doing that
on my behalf because it looks kind of
bad it's looking like i'm asking you
guys to do that i never asked but thank
you but
you know when you get punched in the
face by the older kid and you never
asked your older brother to beat the
[ __ ] out of the guy but when you're
waking up or getting punched your older
brother's just beating that's what
happened so thanks guys even though i
never asked
thanks for having our [ __ ] back
story time
all right
all right
what time we have marty
four to three
hey
we're doing good we're doing good all
right all right i don't know if it's a
coincidence i haven't heard any goddamn
trends i haven't
heard cricket going i haven't heard
anything
you guys
it's amazing in here
it's so cool
the set is so much better
it's our own little world into you now
yeah it's not an open dust
swirl pool sorry tom chong sorry for
making coming here at 105 risking your
life risking your life in here i'm sorry
rick ross for sweating josh wolfe i'm
sorry for making you eat mushrooms and
sweat it out
my bad never again all right we have a
little refrigerator out here in a cool
hallway with plaques green room and a
green room
we actually we have a green room man
with frosted out windows frosted windows
so nobody can stare at you yo we're
official as [ __ ] out here i'm excited
i'm so excited
oh yeah sorry guys
on to another segment it didn't feel
like a real thing until we moved in
until we sat here today and you pressed
camera yeah like i said it felt like uh
oh we just got done with summer league
and now the season started
season one was great
but this is gonna have 52 episodes in
the season
every season maybe 50. we should
probably do 50
so we could just say 50. because those
two weeks with christmas it's gonna be
almost nearly [ __ ] impossible when
you have three kids yeah yeah we'll
figure it out i'll figure it out yeah
but
probably 50. about a year no matter what
in a year i'll be doing pull-ups all
right i said by episode 100.
i'm not too far off from being able to
hold my [ __ ] full body weight
it's just that
pull-up part that gets me down
maybe he's okay it's the no thing that
gets me
half-baked speaking of dave chappelle
okay here we go
guys
another segment coming back from season
one this segment marty named i [ __ ] with
this segment i love this segment because
this is what i try to live by only
positivity and cool and fun stuff unless
you [ __ ] with me and then i get pissed
and then i'm back to being happy and
smoking weed
introduced to the next segment called
what's good season two episode one first
segment installment of what's good i got
some good [ __ ] for you today you ready
real quick that made me think of what
the the nice quote you're gonna put
above your desk don't make me be an
[ __ ] yeah
before we start what's good
you guys and when it comes to business i
am way too nice i am way too nice i give
people way too much percentage
i know what i do i know it i know what i
do when i do these business deals these
companies i'm like no you can take more
it's cool bro it's all
i know i get it which is cool i'm being
nice we all make money that's great when
it comes to people [ __ ] my [ __ ] up
i'm still too nice i'm still too nice
i'm like don't worry man we'll get it
done and i get in my car i'm like [ __ ]
screaming atop my lungs just trying not
to take it out on that person
even though they deserve it because they
[ __ ] their job
and then asked for a tip oh no that's
something different that's something
different guys for the past three weeks
i've been firing the [ __ ] out of people
for the past three weeks i have grown
into a full-sized adult
i got bigger all right
that's how i feel right now
um
i've been firing the [ __ ] out of people
and i had not been happier in my life
i've i've never wanted to fire anybody i
never wanted to do any of that [ __ ] i
never wanted to hurt someone's feelings
or make them like
i never want to [ __ ] someone's day up
that's my thing i never
i stuck with that first videographer
dude that we talked about with og for
way too long because i didn't want to
hurt his [ __ ] feelings by saying bro
i don't really want to work with you
anymore i couldn't bring it up i
couldn't do it even though he was
stressing me
stressing my life out yeah i just
couldn't do it do i i don't want to hurt
no one's feeling i hate making people
feel like [ __ ] i i just can't stand it
but for the past few weeks that [ __ ]
just went away a second that shirt
cracked and i ripped and i remember we
talked about on that show the second
that happened
a demon was born
yeah oh truly truly something went and
flipped in my head yeah and i went no no
you're late now you paid first you paid
on time you gave them everything they
need they [ __ ] their job up
fire these [ __ ] and get your
money
back so i've been doing that
i got upset my clothes are being fixed
they will be here tomorrow good night
great they
push trees drop
dress dropped on friday new grinders new
clothes new sweats new sweaters new
shorts a bunch of dope [ __ ] right
exactly that's how i feel whole [ __ ]
warehouse is empty because everything's
in here i got a gym set up in there
everything's right the whole lot the old
set it's just the gym now i put all the
weights and all the treadmill and all
that [ __ ] it's just one little gym area
it's pretty cool um
so i've been firing the [ __ ] out of
people i fired my chiropractor in my
head
i didn't want he was too nice i couldn't
do it to him but i got there three and
the fool took three patients in front of
me and i was there till 3 40. i went
[ __ ] fired
you're a nice guy but you're [ __ ]
fired i have so much [ __ ] to do today
and that's why i got here on time
just tell me my appointment's 3 40.
don't do that to me but he does it to me
every time marty
he's an ice cube but it happens every
time
and this time like uh you're fired i'm
good but in my head because he's nice
yeah
i haven't i paid an artist an artist
i've never [ __ ] with before i paid
this artist half the deposit because he
asked for how to deposit he's supposed
to give me six items
it took him eight days to give me one
[ __ ] item and i didn't like it so i
had him change it up a little bit right
but we said it would be a week but we're
at day eight and there's only one item
of six done
so i said hey he's like hey man
uh could you actually send more of the
deposit and i normally would have like
been like no
why
but he went you know what it's okay i'm
gonna pay you the full [ __ ] amount
just so he's at home going damn this
will pay me all of it
[ __ ] yeah bro you're the [ __ ] so he
would you know get going on my [ __ ] yeah
i wanted to kill i wanted to be hyped
and happy
so i paid him in [ __ ] full
i decided to just take the [ __ ] three
designs out of six and say
keep the money man you're taking so
[ __ ] long that just give me what you
have
and i'm leaving because i have to do i
need these designs
i told them like yo just keep it it's
all good
and then the guy says yeah since you
know you made some changes just if you
wouldn't mind giving me a tip
i'm gonna [ __ ] slap you through the
screen i've never been more offended
he asked me for a tip because i had to
make changes
i paid him in full for six items so
essentially he should have gave me 650
back right if he only did half the work
yeah but i said keep the 650 and then he
asked me for more [ __ ] money and like
i said guys usually i would have been
like
i'm leaving alone oh no
i [ __ ] fired him immediately
i fired him and went hard politely and
i'm just thinking about you know when
sharks eyes rolls back it was funny
because at first you're like something
you're like i don't want to hurt this
guy's feeling yeah you heard me remember
this guy's feeling supposed to they kept
going you're like he just asked me first
test me for a [ __ ] tip
that's how i felt like are you [ __ ]
serious
you didn't even finish the job
you're [ __ ] fired yeah so i [ __ ]
fired him basically like i'm done no
thank you walk away i'm not giving you
any money and i broke it down like
you're really asking me for money after
you took and i said everything i just
said i said in the email um
did i tell you what happened he copped a
little [ __ ] attitude with me after
that
i don't know if you know that things
aren't just a button and things get done
it's not just a push of a button i don't
know if you know that that's what he
[ __ ] said to me
oh i [ __ ] on him back
i should have him back very politely and
pretty much said well i'm just used to
you know real graphic artists i guess
have a great day
that's how i felt and even right now i
feel like an [ __ ] no but i feel
signed up for when you're a graphic
artist you guys feel mean you're out of
line yeah
you go against the terms oh i mean it
happens don't get me [ __ ] wrong yeah
it's like yo i paid you paint the house
you paid it keep the money bro keep the
money it's fine just go you're done what
about like a tip you know i rushed
that's crazy
that's crazy that's where it turns crazy
that's what pissed me the [ __ ] off so
fired him
i have some people help me with my car
not studio motors some other guys
helping my car i went back for the
fourth time for them to fix my rap today
and they fixed the wrong panel
fix the [ __ ] out of it it fixed the [ __ ]
out of the panel that was done right
and then when i picked up it's done i go
bro it was the other side
and then i came here to film this so i'm
about to go back there and actually out
right now the guy's tinting my windows
outside right now
he showed up on time yeah so he's hired
tense the wrong car tents my truck and
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
the neighbors
attended your warehouse is awesome
get out
so sorry back to what i was saying it
sparked a demon in me and i've been
firing the [ __ ] out of people but also
things are getting done at a pace that
i'm [ __ ] i want
fired new guy fired new guy you're
perfect
then that's where we're at because i'm
[ __ ] done waiting on people i've been
waiting on people my whole life i've
been super polite
very very very considerate i don't want
to hurt no one's feelings and lately i
have just been [ __ ]
not giving a [ __ ]
that's great i mean that's amazing but
there has there is the hammer of it that
is the opposite of that that has to like
make sure that it's a two-way street
well i mean i i you know many times i've
paid people i'm the guy at the
restaurant that will pay for his food
and it comes wrong and i don't say
anything yeah i'm like that's that's me
and i but
carry that into every aspect of life
mm-hmm get cut in line at the store and
i'll say no just let it go
well that's the path of least resistance
and that's i feel like that's fine in
life because a lot of times if it's just
something small it's like
everything's always small but
everything's small things add three
weeks to my order yeah at two weeks
different in business oh i sent the
wrong sample my bad but here's the bill
yeah no and the business is [ __ ] paid
even though you [ __ ] up i'll pay it
yeah but no that's me though i let it go
i let [ __ ] go all day i do not
want to be a [ __ ] burden i'm tired of
i don't like that [ __ ] i don't want to
shoot any phone calls back don't want to
do that to people i don't like it i hate
it i don't want to [ __ ] someone but
lately i don't give a [ __ ] i was just
like email me back you [ __ ] the
artist might yeah email me back i want
to see what the [ __ ] and then you came
at me rude and went oh
you asked for it
and um
that's just what's been going on my
front desk at my building [ __ ] on the
woman
because she's [ __ ] up
but super polite
if you're standing on something solid
it's like we'll go back and forth all
[ __ ] day because
i never picked something going of course
no it's like you got me so upset and you
played me so many times that now i'm
like
this is the kid that you pick on and he
finally blew up i'm ralphie from that
[ __ ] christmas story right now and
i'm beating the [ __ ] out of that scott
ferguson scott that's me right now
to life
and everything's working out better but
that's that's how it has to be though it
has to the universe will push you until
you get like that you know what's funny
dude yeah my friend
he's the one that
here's a little tip
if you have goals in life look at him
every day
he always have like a different thing on
his
screensaver at his house would be
chilling in his room he always has his
office we sit in his office and take
dabs
and like yo that lambo's stupid and he
goes i'm gonna buy that lambo i'm gonna
go for really good i'm gonna get it
watch
and three months later the [ __ ]
got the exact not the one that looks
like it he got the exact lambo that is
on the screen wasn't that scratch that's
powerful and he goes all right cool
changing it what do you do i'm changing
my screen saver i got the car
boom
stupid sick ass [ __ ] culinard
you know what i'm saying like yeah but i
got
i got a pretty crazy ass story about
that type of [ __ ] i'm saying like that
that is yeah
that's how it works
and i've been using that ever since and
since last summer
i had the blue amg
on my screen saver and now it is outside
the [ __ ] warehouse
and i just changed it the other day to
the stupid [ __ ] house i found in
encino the one i showed you yeah it's so
[ __ ] scary that is ridiculous so now
that's my screensaver and the one above
it is the brabus 900 rocket but it's 650
bands it's a car
that's the next goal
i want to get so ballin that i can buy
every one of my family houses and then
go
on to the screensavers
all right now i'm gonna try to get this
like well because i'm not rich at all i
[ __ ] break my apartment uh-huh but
we're gonna [ __ ] we're gonna we're on
the way all right we're on the [ __ ]
way we're doing too much too much work
too much good [ __ ] too much solid stuff
for these revenues not to start
and you know i mean it's just
that's why i'm saying if you have a goal
look at it yeah it's called a vision
board yes
exactly and it's every day because i'm
always on my computer doing [ __ ] so i'm
like i have to stare at this house i
gotta stare at this car i gotta stare
you know what i mean i know it's like
it's materialistic
you grew up dirt [ __ ] poor [ __ ]
and then you tell me what's
materialistic i want a [ __ ] place i
can live in i can live in this room and
be just as happy as my big house
but also i work my [ __ ] ass off and i
want a big ass house that's what i want
to [ __ ] get
and that's the point that's the goal
yeah that's the point
yeah that's the whole i want to walk in
my backyard and almost shed a [ __ ]
tear and go bro you [ __ ] have a house
oh yeah [ __ ] that's what you want
i got i got damn near i felt like i was
gonna [ __ ] yeah you get lightheaded
fall over when they started installing
our kitchen yeah you get a little sick
it's like wow this is your house it's
[ __ ] happening bro yeah it's real
close mary's house is like 92
done yeah it really is it's so
it's a nice asphalt and everything
you're talking about i mean this
everything that i'm experiencing right
now was on my literal vision board marty
go your vision board about the house
yeah go go i mean and me and april and
i's second apartment that we had i used
to sit up in the attic and [ __ ] smoke
balance with my boys and [ __ ] it was my
spot i used to have this little
makeshift desk up there i didn't have a
mirror i literally had a piece of
sharded
glass like a mirror that
cracked and i had that up on my [ __ ]
thing and i would sit up there and write
i had notebooks i look out the window
just listen to the neighborhood and [ __ ]
smoke and on the wall of the attic i had
my vision board and i just look at it
the house though yeah so i had one house
on it it was uh this
mega mansion in la jolla which is
wait la jolla yeah i was watching
million dollar deals this new show i'm
hooked on hgtv because i show like 2
million to 12 million dollar houses in
l.a
yesterday we're in la jolla mm-hmm that
place is on [ __ ] belief yeah it's
amazing i never even knew it existed
sorry keep going the way it's [ __ ]
bald yeah it's amazing it's like
northern san diego it's where yeah it's
like it's mega [ __ ] yeah mega mansions
so anyway i just found this one
mega mansion in la jolla that i just
like fell in love with i was just like
you i had a bunch of different cars on
my vision board i had a bunch of
different like materialistic things with
just one house that i'd really picked
out i thought i was going to end up
moving to san diego
just based kind of based off that i knew
i wanted to move to socal i didn't know
anything about orange county
but
so anyway i had this house on my vision
board for a long time probably a couple
of years it was the only house i ever
had on my vision board and i like looked
up the address i looked up the owner
and started like researching him and
learning about him this fool
funded one of the president's campaigns
this fool owns a
sports team
he owns a major major like you know
target walmart
one of those style stores like this dude
is a legit billionaire
and yeah i picked out his house put it
on my wall and that was my [ __ ] house
and i really that was right around the
time that i had just really rewired my
brain after watching the secret so
that's what got me on manifesting and
believing that i could bring things into
my life that to me is like how people
embrace religion
where i was just like okay okay there is
some there i have some
there's something i can do and
deliberately to try to make my life
better and it's change how i think
and
and focus my energy and my feelings in a
certain deliberate kind of way instead
of just being on autopilot and i used to
be like you know it's very easy to be
like a up here uh i always get [ __ ]
over
of course this [ __ ] happened it's
very easy to get into that whereas when
you change that around it becomes a
completely different conversation in
your head when when the the voice in
your head is uh giving you positive
affirmations
versus like a little beatdown which it i
feel like it defaults to for most people
if you don't really take control of it
but
i started really focusing my attention
or being aware of what i was focusing my
attention on
so
a couple years you know after that this
was um this house was on my vision board
it was on my computer for probably
four to five years
and then i went to a christmas party
at my aunt's house i'm not really
connected to my family i don't i didn't
really like after about seven years old
i didn't really grow up around my family
at all yeah so i was all i was probably
20 um
right it was probably the year before i
moved to california so i'm at 23 24 i go
to a christmas party and i meet a cousin
of mine who i didn't even know existed
didn't even know she existed but she's
my mom's cousin i meet her at this
christmas party i started talking to her
and she's like yeah i live in san diego
i'm you know i do this and that and i'm
like wow it's crazy i tell her i'm
actually gonna move to san diego i'm so
affirmative
i'm like yeah i'm actually gonna move to
southern california even though it was
not in the works at all yeah
and she's like wow here and she starts
like flipping through her picture she's
showing me she's like yeah i live in la
jolla i'm like no [ __ ] my dream house is
in la jolla kind of to myself you know
i'm i'm not all going crazy on her with
all this [ __ ] and then bam she flips to
the house and she's like
she's like uh she flips the house i'm
like that's my dream house that's it
i could tell because of how all the
landscaping and [ __ ] was i had multiple
photos of this house aerial photos with
the paragliders going past it it's on a
cliff on the ocean stop with the
paragliders yeah is it called the razor
house i don't know about that is it i
have a glass and look all [ __ ]
architecturally crazy
there's probably a lot of houses that
look like this house a long time because
but there's an episode i watched last
night the paragliders were next door to
this guy's house there is there there is
paragliders next door to the house yeah
on a cliff and it opens up right to the
ocean like this
but there's this episode last time
although
on the street are like that
probably you know what i mean like they
said on this one like this is the most
expensive house in this neighborhood
i don't know about that they're all this
whole area is like that the whole
stretch
i'm saying i watched this episode last
night there yeah that's crazy that's
crazy the prominent house of the
neighborhood this is the big one that's
what they kept saying it could be it's
very glad i got to watch it because it
very well might be so i'll get to that
so i mean
so that blew my [ __ ] mind in that
moment that was one of the most that was
one of the most mind-blowing moments i'd
ever had that's not this i heard a
different part of this story so
so yeah that's how i was like that's my
[ __ ] dream house
and she goes uh in all actuality i said
that's that's the dream house on my
vision board
is that on such and such boulevard she's
like how do you know that
i'm like does such and such i own that
house that's the house on my vision
board she's like that's my boss she's
like i live in this house six months out
of the year what the [ __ ] she's like i
house at this house tell me this part i
don't know i thought you told me the
other part that was like wow that's
crazy this part's
crazier so crazy
so i never met my cousin before she's a
little bit older than me she's almost my
mom's age she's my mom's cousin okay uh
she moved out to california she was 20
or whatever so i never was even aware of
her
i didn't even know she existed what are
the odds of this yeah so oh tell the
next part tell the next part she's like
i live there you know all this [ __ ]
so
this is in the midst of me going through
that whole dj ski thing like right right
before that and she's like all right
well whenever you move out to california
like let me know so i started staying in
touch with her she's like uh
put me on the ted talks put me on to
like little just you know we started
staying in touch yeah i mean you know
but uh so then i had to make your own
luck campaign going with rob dear deck
and like i told you he favored it on
twitter i told dj skee about the [ __ ]
and it was looking like
they were gonna let me do the music
video down there if i would have been
able to get deer deck on board to do the
music video
i possibly could have shot to make your
own luck video with rob dyrdek in my
[ __ ] dream house
but that didn't end up panning out i
flew out here went back when i moved to
california about two weeks later we went
down to the [ __ ] dream house and i
chilled in it all day long
so you pull up to this massive estate it
had this giant exotic bird aviary next
to it
and like right we pulled up we parked
she came out we might ariana was like
six at the time five she went up to the
av area she's like oh nobody can go in
there he the owner is the only one that
goes in there he was in africa at the
time
and she's like yeah he goes in there and
comes out all [ __ ] bloody and like
these birds the bird came up it's like
[ __ ] avatar in there the
blue purple [ __ ] bird came up to the
door all crazy and [ __ ] but then we went
into the house and i got all these
pictures this [ __ ] is covered
pictures up on this yeah
yeah on um with just african sculptures
she's like this is a million this is 5
million 15 million just
architecture sculptures everywhere and
then the back side of the house which i
didn't realize from the photos was a
complete organic farm
it's the backyard is so big it was a
farm where it was rows and rows and rows
and rows of all their fruits and
vegetables
and then this sick-ass giant infinity
pool that we swam in and children all
[ __ ] day
and the people next door were
paragliding they're jumping off the
[ __ ] cliff it's the same house
i don't know how paragliding works you
it's seemingly you slowly fall to your
death but you don't die at the end
that's exactly what you're looking at
don't over the ocean i want to know who
the first guy was to successfully
paraglide and how many [ __ ] ups happened
yeah it's like the airplane it's like
the earliest versions of the airplane
all right all right
you know it's just your whole body is
yeah there's the plane yeah i don't know
still how that [ __ ] works but yeah they
were doing that and um it completely it
let in that moment i remember when i was
in the pool i'm with my daughter in this
pool i'm like oh this is real this
manifestation vision board [ __ ] is a
really it made me feel really powerful
and then i just kept going with that
from there and i'm still in touch with
my cousin this day she's [ __ ]
crushing it and
that was life-changing but to everybody
out there it might not seem real but
that [ __ ] really works i think
we live in a
earth is like a video game earth is like
a computer i think simulation style
that's how i think in my head so it's
like
how do you upgrade in the game
you get to the next level
but what if you can't find the key to
get to the door to the next level
imagine that [ __ ] everything that is
once
was a thought from somebody that's in
the secret yes every is it everything
that exists started as a thought i think
when you think so you can't be
manifesting too hard out in public
i think your thoughts are energy that
come out of your body and somebody walks
by and boop
they and you have audio pop in your head
the car that went by you was thinking of
some good [ __ ] and it flew out you can
measure a thought a brain wave is a
tangible real thing oh well there it is
yeah you can measure that's why i mean
it is a real thing there's really just
something i thought yeah i was high one
day i guess
just thinking like you know what og
taught me about that too he's like you
know what i think we both agreed on that
like yo thoughts are just like that's
how you get [ __ ] pops in your head
because it [ __ ] flew out of someone's
head over there and landed on you and
you're like what the [ __ ] uh electricity
i don't know like crazy [ __ ] but that's
how i was thinking like yo imagine it
uh what is it what i just [ __ ] i am
completely
[ __ ]
brain dead
how come i can't think of
the word
that i'm talking about okay let's work
this out let's figure this out let's
figure this out this just happened on
camera
manifestation thank you okay
why couldn't i think of the old word not
a word you use every day it's
but it's right there
um
manifestation is just like uh
holding l1 on gta and it brings up your
items
it's like oh well there's nothing there
well let's go get some of that [ __ ]
that's how i think it is it's like boom
a manifestation is your dreams what are
your thoughts you ever think about stuff
and you dream about it
that's how i think like that happens why
did i dream about [ __ ] shooting
people all night oh yeah i watched
bloody blood out last yeah for sure yeah
that's
that's your brain doing like auto
declutter or some [ __ ] yeah exactly it's
clearing your cookies out and [ __ ]
yeah it's not too off no no you got that
bro yes manifestations that's real
though sometimes it takes years for it
to come together but if you need proof
look at how all this [ __ ] [ __ ] came
together with us like
you know that was sometimes you don't
even realize what you're manifesting you
get there like this is better than i
even could have [ __ ] wish for just
like this background better than i
wished for he did the search because i
was doing uh computer work i came in
here and went oh my god
you're already [ __ ] crushing it
and that's when i realized like oh we
picked the right [ __ ] to make
this spot yeah um
yeah that's just [ __ ] cool hey what's
up guys just wanted to take a quick
break to tell you about one of our
sponsors and since it's the very first
ad read of season two thank you guys so
much as i said before thank you for
watching the ads thank you for
supporting the brands to support us
thank you for actually clicking the
links in our description thank you for
using the codes we [ __ ] appreciate it
so you've seen it on our show before the
lawnmower 4.0 the updated version the
3.0 is a thing of the past but something
manscape just came out with this is the
refined body wash this is the body wash
for your everyday use this is not just
for shaving also something else that
marty and i really recommend you guys
have seen it before this is the
performance package 4.0 this comes with
the ball toner the ball yes i said toner
the ball deodorant the underwear the 4.0
lawnmower and the weed whacker but it
also comes with that bag and you just
don't have to put your trimmers in there
marty keeps all of his batteries and
stuff if you saw in our other video
marty actually has a manscape bag and he
keeps all of his batteries and his gear
in it two of them
two of them sorry two of them so right
now go to
manscape.com forward slash yola and that
is 20 off plus free shipping it doesn't
get any better than that guys if you
were going to get manscaped anyway or
you want maybe it's time for you to
re-up on your razors try manscaped out
it can't hurt it's one time if you love
it you've got a new brand for life if
you don't like it i doubt it from
personal experience guys it is awesome
to have all the tools you need i know
it's like you need tools like you do
need tools and if you think you don't
need tools
this isn't for you but if you don't like
being super nasty you like to be well
groomed hit up manscape.com like i said
manscape.com forward slash yolo that's
20 off plus free shipping back to the
episode
before we keep going guys the ad reads
thank you so much marty and i have we've
been really working hard to lock in
really really solid ad partners so thank
you guys for supporting those people
thank you for supporting those brands
using our code even if you click the
link in the description by the way every
product we ever talk about every product
we ever do in the ad reads it's in the
description you can click the link and
it goes right to their website all of
our information for the ad read is in
the comments too it's linked in the
comments at the very top or it's in the
video description so guys thank you so
much for supporting that it really helps
us every time you buy manscape you guys
you guys do on it like would i be
whoever it might be blue man thank you
guys it really helps us it really makes
us look better when you're like yeah our
audience
supports it just helps i just don't want
to take ad reads
and they go hey it's not [ __ ] helping
us
what the [ __ ] i don't want to take
people's money if it's not going to help
that's really in the end like we want
the ad partners to go no dope as usual
podcast [ __ ] yeah we always work with
them they do great they always help us
out that's what i want to hear i would
rather take a little less [ __ ]
money and the [ __ ] work well then us
take a bunch of [ __ ] money from
people and it does nothing so thank you
guys as i always say thank you for
supporting the brands and support us
marty that was a fat ass rip
i just saw a ghost cloud
come out behind the camera
oh [ __ ] all right let's get back into
drugs
thank you sponsor thank you sponsors
thank you
if you're in the car please be safe uh
here we go back on what i was trying to
talk about 30 are you using a torch
lighter
you are a monster
what's wrong with the door you're using
a torch lighter to hit the pipe party
you are a heavy smoker you don't know it
if you can take that and it didn't kill
you you're a beast
just
the most butane you can have and you're
just ripping it
you want to try the have you ever tried
i'm not i'm not listening have you tried
it
no
you've never tried it i mean i know i've
never had my own like hempwick thing i
mean i'm pretty [ __ ] just quick i
know but
yeah it's probably smarter
can you try this later yeah that's fine
everybody always asks what's on your
lighter it's hempwick all right there's
this company called hempwick i know
there's a lot of brands that make it but
the brand hempwick they're super [ __ ]
nice people it's a [ __ ] family-owned
business basically
they're very very very nice they're very
cool
hempwick right it's just beeswax all
right that's all it is
and you light it when you smoke bowls
you light a joint because when you hit
you ever hit a bowl
this is not an ad by the way i just
[ __ ] love these guys it's a tutorial
i've been using this since 2011
before i ever started instagram i was
using hemp wig
um you ever light a bowl and you're
about to at the end of the bowl
you suck it through you taste lighter
fluid yeah you ever get that lighter
taste because you
kill i know you have you have to right
marty
yeah
yeah yeah i mean you ever hit a bowl
you're like damn it tastes bomb and you
hit the same bowl later but at the end
you're like dude it's hot like tastes
like lighter fluid like a chemical a
little bit that's because you're sucking
through that flame
you're sucking a butane you're sucking
in lighter fluid or whatever it is
it leaves a taste with hemp wick it's
just weed
alls you taste is smoke
put it this way i can close my eyes hit
a bowl and i'll tell you if you use
hemwick
because i'll be like dana tastes like
lighter i always say damn that tastes
like high school
you ever hear me say that tastes like
high school it's because i'm like
dancing like straight lighter fluid [ __ ]
i used to rip everything resin with
lighters
crackling resin [ __ ] um that's why i use
hemp wick man like watch watch because i
hit bong so much the difference is night
and day
but you can rip bowls with those
lighters yeah that's what i'm doing you
can torchable but you can also do the
circle technique there's this guy on the
internet he does like tutorials on we
[ __ ] sometimes there's a video called
how to use a bong and he gets a great
great descript the overhead lights are
on uh-huh it looks great in here yeah i
just noticed the overhead lights around
okay sorry guys
some bts sure
um
yeah he does tutorials and you know he
shows you how to hit a bong go watch
that sh that had to hit a bong it's on
youtube it's some dude does bomb rips
and [ __ ] and uh yeah hempwick is the way
to go i won't i'd rather not smoke weed
without heavily yeah
yeah i've been aware of it i've just
never like never gotten more i just
smoked like after the lung infections i
got in like 2015 from all that those
packs
my lungs are like [ __ ] they're
sensitive it's like walking on an
asphalt barefoot like oh that's how i
feel like oh i need sh i need shoes
that's how i feel like is it flushed
it's not flush it tastes bad like i'm
such a [ __ ] now bro but i also smoke
the [ __ ] fire now
yeah that's like oh you gotta pack i'll
take the zip of fire over that pound
thank you i know i get all your
throwaway weed and it's awesome oh it's
all fire [ __ ] i know it's just like [ __ ]
i i like a certain weed i like a certain
type of weed like i said like every i
know what kind of weed you like
that's why i'm like marty here take us
take this
always i can't tell the difference
between i know but i haven't really
given you crazy like sativa strawberries
because i wouldn't know i don't know if
you like them
because you shouldn't
you like heavy sheets i don't even look
marty took a fat dab the other day and
did this
and i was saying oh my god marty's
monster
he's a dabber so uh yeah you've
rekindled my love for hash though for
sure yeah it's uh it's coming soon all
right marge should be dabbing his ass
off soon
guys what time we at 119. oh [ __ ]
yeah 119. yeah still got it got that
[ __ ] you guys ready oh hour and a half
that's not going to happen [ __ ]
here we go ready
go here comes a segment we tried to talk
about half an hour ago and they got
sidetracked somehow here we go
this segment's called what's good what's
good all right this is good news this is
for good news and there has been some
pretty [ __ ] epic news that i have
found in the past couple days are you
guys ready
what's good i don't know how to say this
immunotherapy
there's a drug immunotherapy drug
and for cancer patients and it has been
in the past trial past couple trials
it's been so effective that tumors are
disappearing in weeks
cancerous tumors are disappearing in
weeks
for this new [ __ ] drug that they're
using in the new trials
that's just [ __ ] awesome i said neck
and head cancer patients have recovered
i've
seen tremendous
uh
drop in something sellable well but the
tumors have disappeared within weeks
that's crazy it's crazy that it's i mean
ah like we need that [ __ ] right now
thank you that's like that's a [ __ ]
win dude oh yeah that's good [ __ ]
there's somebody out there that just
woke up with that news and now they're
like
what'd you say could you imagine how
different the world would be if cancer
was curable
[ __ ]
that's crazy like i mean
that that'd be a [ __ ] game changer
that's something to bring the world
together
i mean it's crazy that we had i mean
they haven't found a any sort of cure up
until this point there is there there's
yeah out there but
they're not like
the pill cure yeah it'll work for sure
diet this cleanse
you can get rid of stuff in your body
because it was put there for the stuff
you put in your body
you can get it out with stuff that you
put back in your body the good [ __ ]
it's like replacing it
oh you're full we'll stuff you full of
the good [ __ ] and all the bad stuff's
gone literally all the bad stuff's gone
just read all right read [ __ ]
holistic [ __ ] diet has a lot to do with
stuff
diet has almost every [ __ ] link to
every disease known to man
what are you eating what are you exposed
to what's your environment
that's really it's really like what it
is man but with this right here it's
just such a such a wind
so that's why i put that in what's good
i am [ __ ] high marty
i don't know why i feel so [ __ ] high
i was looking at the camera
and then thinking
yo this is that's crazy man it says live
i can't see the screen this is not live
there's no live chat i'm [ __ ] burnt
that's all i was about to say where's
the live chat yeah
we've never done a live podcast but
we've been talking about it maybe that's
why all right maybe i had a dream last
night and bank the [ __ ]
i don't know what happened but i i just
almost said that i'm [ __ ] burnt guys
what's good all right cancer [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you okay here we go [ __ ] you
um we should get the fans feedback on
that though cause what i'm doing live
podcast like live on youtube
i gotta be honest bro i'm not mad at
that
maybe for the first 20 minutes
yeah i mean the first 20 minutes leave
the phone up that right there put on
airplane mode
yeah disturb yeah yeah
we could figure it out i think even by
season three like if we were if we were
to really nail down the live switch we
could do it yeah cause we uh guys we
don't stop
the podcast just keeps going yeah
you know i mean well actually today we
did stop for like 10 seconds because i
had to make sure the guy that was
tinting my car didn't black out the
windows but it was the ad break and it
was also an ad break right but in
reality i had called rose you go yo can
you make sure he's not blocking it out
because the last cars he was doing for
studio motors were
celebrity people and he was black 100
black tin on every window i don't want
to go out there and go [ __ ] it's illegal
as [ __ ] to have that
so you have to have a permit for that
and i don't have that permit
so uh
yeah we took a little break but anyway
live
just dude these tangents and rants
you made it back though i don't i did
make it back it's like a lightning
strike when it goes
i was like about 10 seconds ago i was
like [ __ ] where were we yeah and then i
went
live switching live chat live okay
gotcha
oh
the lightning went and then came back
came back all right you know the only
person of the season
to get lost on a tangent with me and
then bring it back successfully super
proper was boo johnson
back to yeah we'll bring that up later
back to what i was saying when i get up
and i do that i go oh my god you
remember
that's how i felt
like wow all right i gotta get back on
my [ __ ] cuz this guy's smoking too okay
but that's just my life i forget about
eight i'll walk into the kitchen go what
the [ __ ] was i doing yeah why did i
commend you i didn't come in it's me
every day i'm sure all you guys do that
[ __ ] too but yeah live podcast we're
gonna do some live shows
i'm excited that means i have to wear
pants and not shorts because the
audience will just be staring at me
doing
little [ __ ] just me in my legs just
[ __ ] around the whole time
we'll get to it marty we will get live
we're we're going to do it yeah i'm
excited
guys it's season two
we're coming into our to our own
what was it last year was about branding
all right [ __ ] yeah that's all this
year's about expanding exactly all right
we gotta get us somebody even said you
gotta get a sign uh
seinfeld i was thinking that earlier
when you were telling your stories we
need that [ __ ]
hey i know i'm slipping i gotta update
this one i'm gonna do some cool
soundboard [ __ ] and we're gonna get
[ __ ] west side gun
oh backward or saying any words
[Music]
it's the voice of like a five-year-old
but it's just saying
the worst [ __ ] you could think of that's
going on oh the way he talks yeah it's
like oh okay i can see that with kids
like hey
oh wow i never thought about it like
that
yeah it's like very like elementary
school yeah i never thought well i
noticed my kids talk like that that i
was like that's [ __ ] west side gun
that's the voice maybe that's where i
might be yeah that's just hard i was
walking around for a [ __ ] week saying
everything like that bro yeah i love
that [ __ ] if you guys don't know who
westside gun is of griselda you're
slipping
go listen to anything i love all of it
i love all of it just the [ __ ]
sound effects out of nowhere the full
saying mad wild elegant ass [ __ ] like
did you just say you're wearing a 30 000
outfit while you shot someone in the
mouth i love this who is this and then i
saw the video i'm like yo that jacket
it's amazing damn that jacket is tight
son
that's how i felt oh yeah i love west
side guns oh yeah i love what he's doing
for buffalo too [ __ ] and they're out of
your city bro yeah i mean he put a
goddamn listen
listen guys he put a store in the walden
galleria malt the biggest mall in
western new york he has his own store in
it called buffalo kids that [ __ ] is
iconic
i mean
[ __ ] benny has official bills merch
he's an official bill's brand ambassador
he shoots music videos on the field
he's got branded bills merch with the
[ __ ] pyrex
and him on it this [ __ ] is
crazy that just shows you buffalo's down
with it yeah they're like whatever no no
let's [ __ ] do a pyrex yeah we like to
cook stuff too man i posted a video on
my story i reposted a video on my story
the other day the mayor of buffalo going
buffalo city of chicken wings all this
and one of the greatest rappers to ever
live west side conway what the the mayor
of buffalo byron brown did a conway
trailer home of one of the greatest
rappers to ever live
boom boom boom boom boom like this [ __ ]
is crazy that i mean
i haven't heard that group come out in
so long that makes me go bro when's the
next [ __ ] coming out yeah it was the
next [ __ ] coming out of a long time ago
that was sick
yeah it doesn't exist in hip-hop most
groups it's funny we bring up griselda
so much yeah hell yeah it's just because
it's been in my head since we got this
warehouse that's what i was bumping when
we're moving in it's just crazy it's
part of pop culture and it's like i love
it dude i love it i love that it's
getting so popular [ __ ] yeah and to
coincide with the bills beating the [ __ ]
out of everybody last night and you're
from buffalo he's crazy artists from
buffalo you know yeah worked with them
already when you were like a kid it's
weird it's just weird to like yeah oh
you guys are finally doing it huh it's
our duty to pick that [ __ ] up
dude that's like if some crazy ass fool
from merced i'm like yo yeah [ __ ] yeah
when i was doing my [ __ ] this one was
doing this [ __ ] yeah exactly
we'll have that one day for merced that
jalen green kid is from merced though
the guy from the houston rockets so i
[ __ ] with that oh yeah um
but yeah dude uh
that was what's good i don't know how
the [ __ ] we oh cause
we talked about westside gun
how he talks i love it uh here we go
another part of my what's good segment
okay
what's good another one are you ready
for this
this is pretty [ __ ] awesome i don't
know why when i saw the article in
that's cool as [ __ ]
ready
it just says dementia ridden patient
this guy was a music conductor
he just conducted a full symphony at 81
with dementia
just off muscle memory
because rosie used to be a nurse's
assistant
and
rosie would tell me when she puts music
on for each patient the [ __ ] that they
know they like because you know in their
file be like oh you're from there oh
they're from here oh he's from mexico so
rosie blake got punished mexican songs
from when he was blah blah and all of
them were like
attitude change
don't know what it is dude
people in comas
people with severe dementia when you
play music that they they know
it's like
they're in that emotion when they first
heard it
and they kind of like come out of it
it's a very odd thing for people that
have family members with dementia or any
kind of alzheimer's style diseases a
very ignorant [ __ ] i don't know
what it's called alzheimer's dimension
that's what i know you're forgetful
so um
play some music from when they were
younger
try that [ __ ] so this guy straight
muscle memory conducting a full [ __ ]
symphony and then just goes right back
to forgetting what he's done
how horrible how horrible but
how [ __ ] awesome hmm because you're
gonna be worse
that guy that says their whole day he
used to be a conductor yeah
[ __ ]
that's sad but at least he gets up and
he's like yeah what's up guy bill what's
up bill
puts it down it goes right back to
sitting down
oh
man
that's sad but it's like uh
okay hear me out hear me out you guys
have seen 50 first dates
hear me the [ __ ] out
you guys have seen 50 first dates
you yeah
you guys know if you haven't seen it
drew barrymore plays a girl that has
[ __ ] alzheimer's because she hit her
head and a coconut or some [ __ ] hit her
all right here we go that's not really
what happened and adam sandler is over
here trying to like bang her but he's
like yo i really love you but you know i
gotta i gotta make you fall in love with
me and then the penguin and seal all
that [ __ ] you guys ready here we go and
rob schneider so here we go um
every time she goes to sleep
she forgets every single thing again and
she keeps going back to the day she got
in the car accident that made her forget
her that made her lose her memory
every morning she wakes up thinking it's
that same morning
when she goes to sleep
it like restarts her brain and she goes
back like groundhog day for her but she
doesn't know
you guys have seen the movie why doesn't
that [ __ ] just stay awake for one night
why isn't that hoe hit the pookie one
time
see what the [ __ ] happened yeah pulling
all night she's in hawaii
second home of meth ice it's called ice
brother
go smoke some ice [ __ ]
go smoke some meth stay awake for one
night did they ever try to go yo it's
12. you should probably get to sleep
they never once said hey let's see what
happens when she stays awake let's get
[ __ ] [ __ ] face tonight maybe she'll
wake up you know different tomorrow
maybe if she doesn't go to sleep
all right i'm gonna just say this and
freddy krueger those kids were trying to
stay awake
longer than the [ __ ]
in [ __ ] 51st dates even though the
imaginary guy in your dreams was murking
you
come on
rudy
rudy is her brother's not gonna help he
didn't once try to go hey
stay awake
i know that movie too well
but come on man
sorry i don't know why brother oh
alzheimer's i'm an [ __ ]
i was talking about this really nice
what's good segment talking [ __ ]
said to hear me out i'm gonna draw a
comparison here okay did i i hope it did
yeah all right cancelled
cancelled
okay here we go i only cancel alarm
clocks [ __ ] i only cancel alarms
in the morning
cancel anybody
john gruden got cancelled though but
here we go
what's good
[Laughter]
anyway drew barrymore you should have
smoked a bowl of bath tried uh what i
want to know is in the end of the movie
when they wake up when she wakes up and
the movie's playing and she goes out on
the boat and she's like oh my god you're
adam sandler at the end of the movie
they have a kid
what was it like every day waking up
[ __ ] six months pregnant
they skipped that part for a reason for
the 50 first dates to when she was
impregnated on the ocean
and had a child
bro what the [ __ ]
every morning wake up next to adam
sandler now hear me out [ __ ] you're
seven months pregnant i did it to you
you live on the water
that's a good point hear me out yeah
go to sleep and you're going to wake up
tomorrow and we're going to be fine
that's how i think like yo what is going
to happen and that is the movie review
of 50 first dates
nobody gets sick every time she wakes up
you're like listen i'm awesome i'm
amazing honestly you don't know what
anything about me that you love to find
other chicks and like you know do cool
[ __ ] and record it you know you just
record it and then you come back
yo that is going to get you canceled
that's called 51st date rapes
yo this [ __ ] today yeah this
brain over here today is on it it's
working today yeah that's 50 first date
rapes
[ __ ] man all right we just got to stop
i don't know what i'm doing to myself
out here that wasn't the onnet that came
up with that idea just that was not
alpha brain that was [ __ ]
oh you know what i'm gonna stop i gotta
stop i had i had a good one in my head i
was like oh you know just leave it
attached
next
every time i'm about to say something
too offensive i want you to bring an
overlay over the screen and i'm gonna go
like this
next just like in the show next and it's
gonna pop up three facts next to me
can we do that could we do that like a
baseball card like right here if i went
could you ding
a overlay over the screen of me like on
a baseball stats card uh-huh i guess
we'll find out yeah
i'm gonna start doing that every time i
need to shut the [ __ ] up because i'm
about to be offensive i'm just gonna go
next
and i'm gonna turn my hip like girls and
pictures hmm
youtube
all right let's get you with your
non-recommended ass
you hate me recommending the
[ __ ] well he did just say 51st
date raves
and said she should smoke a pookie
okay
but in our defense that was your first
time you recommend somebody smoke meth
for sure yeah yeah so there no also in
in
there's a reason there's no mexicans and
[ __ ] freddy krueger
because freddy cougars never try to
fight a mexican that's been up for six
days on meth
all right and effort will stab himself
he don't give a [ __ ] about you
freddy krueger you only hit up [ __ ]
suburban towns uh-huh you never come to
[ __ ] east l.a or boyle heights and
try to stab one it's merciless
seventh [ __ ] day a slow wig
did you want magic oh i'm making the
skit [ __ ] full twacked out
he thinks he's falling he falls asleep
freddy starts smoking meth because he's
got to stay awake long enough
stop it i love that so much
i love that so much i love that
uh-huh you know what's really bad is i
just imagine myself all fat in a [ __ ]
freddy cougar outfit thinking like yo
how am i gonna do this skit
but there's no way otherwise i can't do
it i was just thinking like me hitting a
pookie in a freddy krueger outfit
is [ __ ] hysterical that's that sounds
like a t-shirt
[Laughter]
yo
sorry guys the apparel is coming back
soon all right we got you uh freddy
krueger hit the pookies coming soon and
he's gonna be like that
and the smokey's gonna say dope as usual
oh
come on
yo if any artists out there want to
[ __ ] draw it up for us we will gladly
i'm gonna make it no matter what but if
i'm making it and i find an artist goes
hey by the way i did i watched that
episode here go all right here's some
money
thanks
freddie cougar freddy's got the like the
knives on his hands right yeah that'd be
sick a brick wall back yo can we get the
[ __ ] off this topic okay what's the time
what's the time 1 30 8. yeah
all right here we go we're gonna keep on
two hours here
all right here we go guys uh [ __ ]
talking about freddy cougar hitting the
pokey what the [ __ ] is wrong we're not
getting this another podcast
you're not yeah you're not gonna get
this i'm getting this podcast seth rogen
story time uh and we can't be going
after this man he's nice man he's a nice
guy let him do his thing
marty
he needs to be on the [ __ ] soundboard
i was just looking for a seth rogen drop
do his laugh real quick for me
i like that title there we go
yeah
god dude you know what sucks oh that's
that's not the one that's pretty close i
can't believe you have a bowl
you got to stop people are in their cars
you can't do that in full [ __ ] sound
effects this surrounds town some people
downtown probably driving
just here just [ __ ]
i'm just gonna start pumping through
some real offensive [ __ ] through the
soundboard here hey man you can get
yourself canceled on me
we interviewed adam sandler yesterday
guys it was something
now we just did a test sound run to make
sure all this new equipment worked and i
pretended that i was interviewing adam
sandler and i had such a blast
manifestation
all right here we go just shot you at
the end yeah he did all
he did shoot me at the end i forgot
people would probably think i'm a
[ __ ] idiot like you forgot what you
made up about your own fake [ __ ]
interview i did [ __ ] you it sure was on
the fly it was
it was here we go guys i want to tell a
story before i get out of here okay
uh dude i love the segments i like the
segments yeah i like it i like it all
right here we go first two hour podcast
guys before i get into this i want to
say
if you are watching right now please do
not forget to hit the [ __ ] like
button on youtube that [ __ ] helps the
algorithm because we are shadow band
again
i don't know i'll just leave it at that
all right say it let's leave it that we
gotta manually grab our channel yeah we
have to on all fronts yes for real we're
not allowed on recommended pages anymore
i guess because maybe because i told
drew barrymore to hit the pookie
maybe because i called a [ __ ] 51st
date rapes
could be could be
marty could be
[ __ ] here you go
we're going to have a bunch of guests
this year about the booking agent we're
working on a bunch of [ __ ] i'm about to
be on a bunch of different podcasts
we're
like we said
last year was just getting started like
marty said it was summer leagues the
season has now started last year was so
fun but now we know what we should have
done different we should have been in
here
so much better it's so much better in
here but it's not [ __ ] real it feels
like we're actually doing a podcast it
feels unbelievable here man i'm looking
past you and that used to be a wide open
[ __ ] window
and now there's bars and sound
insulation and a new wall in front of it
and then foam and then the [ __ ]
screen
professionally done professionally done
everything
i'm excited when we started pumping
insulation inside the walls i was like
this is serious
yeah yeah that was fun
yup and 141 no helicopters or trains
something had to go past oh no
helicopters trains or crickets no
okay no let's see if we get through this
all right episode one season two
we should have a tea with the cricket
hitting the [ __ ] pookie too because
clearly that was it stays up all night
yeah
messed out qriket we had to pick it
that's it sleeps during the day that's
for sure yes
i chased a cricket out of here last
night with a broom oh [ __ ]
i can't kill bugs i feel bad so i'm
sitting there like come on [ __ ]
hop in this direction it took so long
for me to guide a [ __ ] cricket out of
here last night and she was whack as
[ __ ] but it left
on his own terms on his own turns and i
closed the door anything after that i
don't feel bad anymore ready
let's get back on topic i'm gonna start
doing it and because i do story times on
my channel
marty
can you do some type of overlay every
time we're about to get into a story all
right guys this segment is another
segment called story time
all that stuff
what sound ball about what sound you're
about to hit i see you i see he's trying
to decide
should i decide
all right i [ __ ] with that that took a
long time for you to hit the
button
yeah there we go that seems appropriate
uh all mixed together explosion that's
the sound you just have exactly [ __ ]
with it so uh every time we do this i'm
gonna start doing segment news
we're getting it that way it's more like
chapters because you guys always ask add
bookmarks add [ __ ] timestamps
i'm gonna try to start doing that stuff
there's a lot of stuff we haven't been
doing and real quick before we start the
story time go to dope as usual podcast
clips that's our clips channel we just
hit 38k this morning thank you guys so
[ __ ] much for that we're about to hit
three million views on the clip channel
which is very cool hell yeah pretty
[ __ ] cool and for the first time ever
we just put out uh educational video on
the clip channel for anybody that wants
to know about or find out about cameras
what you should do for your if you're
starting videographer photographer won't
go too far into it so i want you guys to
watch this [ __ ] marty breaks down his 10
[ __ ] years of experience and all the
trial and error and what not to do and i
come in and talk [ __ ] for about 30
seconds
come in
uh
watch it it's on the dope as usual clips
channel that's linked in our description
just or check the
comment section
uh we have the pinned comments we put
all our titles all our descriptions and
pins in there so check it out guys that
is tips it's called pro tips
videographers photographers smarties all
the experience what you should have so
if you're out there trying to get this
[ __ ] done for real and trying to be if
you were marty was 10 years ago expedite
it by watching that [ __ ] video and
not spend your money on [ __ ] you didn't
need that's the big kicker that's really
what it is that's why i do how to start
a clothing company because i went
through eight years of trial and error
yeah so that's why i do that video on
the avengers yola channel so you guys
don't have to [ __ ] suffer through the
[ __ ]
and most people charge you for it but
[ __ ] that here's the information it's a
nice way for us to give back to you guys
for supporting us thank you for [ __ ]
watching so we're going to help you guys
with whatever you ask so
leave a comment what do you guys want to
see so there you go guys sorry story
time
um
there it is
sorry the tip guy's outside
sorry he said make sure he wasn't
calling me guys my bad my bad
um
here we go
here we go story time uh let me explain
this to you guys because i've seen
hundreds of comments on the college
episode the chaos on campus episode 33
how the [ __ ] did i remember episode 33 i
don't know
so every time i tell a story time on
this channel on the podcast
i am taking a story
from the story time series i do on the
dopaziola channel
so i'm gonna start telling you what it
was from so you can go watch it if you
want to or you know
where it was from or what season it's
from just to have a little more context
okay we can't show packs or weed on here
so marty in this edit can you just quick
overlay maybe blur out the [ __ ] packs
on the screen but this
story that i'm about to tell you is from
season two of story time and this is uh
the title my fit my first party
this is called my first party story time
that's what this episode and this one's
going to be called i mean that's what
this story is from damn i'm out here
[ __ ] up my words here we go
so that's the new thing i'm gonna start
doing season two if i tell you a story
i'll tell you what [ __ ] episode it's
from on my dope as yellow channel so you
can
lock them together and know what's going
on so
first story of season two this is
episode one [ __ ] here we go
this is my first party and this is from
season two of story time
wow that was very
that was confusing there we go that was
it you broke that [ __ ] all the way down
yeah i did i did i did here we go
so
what time we at 146
wow
you're on your [ __ ] today
46. we do not even have the screen where
you see i know i can't even see that
possibly can't see the time
but for everybody out there going you're
wrong he's not right
yeah i remember
our time where right he adds the ads in
and the intro
so that throws off the time on no time
you're looking like himself [ __ ]
i'm right don't be out here leave a
comment like hey [ __ ] you're three
minutes up i'm on point all right here
we go
so this is the story i'm about to tell
you you guys have talked you guys have
heard about me talking about my grandpa
tom my grandpa tom is the reason why i'm
named thomas my grandpa tom was a
[ __ ] baller and a cool [ __ ]
he looked just like eric estrada he
looked just like ponch
from
chips
my grandpa looked a lot like him he's a
very good looking mexican dude that's my
grandpa man he was very [ __ ] cool
so
now i'm gonna tell you this i was about
i was
19 years i was 19 years old i live on
sixth street with my grandpa this is
after my grandma passed away and if
you've listened to other story times and
if you haven't let me tell you my
grandma lived on sixth street my whole
life i she raised me basically when my
mom wasn't around
um or if she wasn't around working
whatever it was
my grandma i were very close she was the
closest person i was ever close i was
never closer to anybody but my grandma
besides rosie
okay so it's weird because they're born
three days apart their birthdays is kind
of odd
but
ro other than that my grandma's the
closest person i was ever
by far when she passed away it was
[ __ ] up for me my grandpa was all by
himself i moved in there a year after
she passed away
yeah i moved in like a year after she
passed away then i moved out my friend
steve got the apar
long story anyway it doesn't matter
i'm living with my grandpa at the time
okay
i'm live with my grandpa at the time and
here's what happened
he retires three years after my grandma
dies he's or two years after my
grandmother's he retires
and my grandma got some gets a
motorcycle and a badass new silverado on
like 24 inch rims
i came home one day
to a
giant red brand new silverado on huge
rims
i walk in the house
i open the door i look at my grandpa he
always said cross leg like one leg over
his knee always sat there and like shook
his foot like an old man thing
i walk in he's not watching tv he's
looking at me like this wait look at the
door like that
i walk in he's just staring at me go
grandpa
he goes like that
you like that i go grandpa you bought
this truck he goes you like it i go it's
badass i'm like oh my god and i started
going like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] he's like
come on and he goes out there he showed
me all the [ __ ] like wow
as soon as you retired you went hard
then he bought a [ __ ] motorcycle and
then an ultima that's what was bawling
after his retirees went [ __ ] it i'm just
spending [ __ ] money my grandpa passed
away like two years after this it's
really [ __ ] he was starting to do cool
[ __ ] then he passed away but
this time he got the motorcycle give me
a little backstory he got a little
motorcycle so sick he started going on
runs my grandpa watched the movie wild
hogs and decided to get a [ __ ]
motorcycle guys the one with tim allen
that wild hog and john gervalto that one
my grandpa thought it was the coolest
[ __ ] ever and he was gonna go off and
have adventures with his friends and
that's exactly what the [ __ ] he did in
the last two years of his life my
grandpa had chaps on i watched my
grandpa put on chaps and when are you
grandpa
now they look cool grandpa in my head
like damn grandpa those chaps are whack
man
what the [ __ ] you do oh it's cool man
it's cool so he was going on his
motorcycle rides with my uncle robert my
uncle robert wilhelm is a badass he's
[ __ ] hilarious he's super cool him
and my grandpa been friends they're
about 15 years old they're about 65
right here
super [ __ ] cool guy i love that dude
so he's like hey i'm working at me and
ed selling weed still selling weed out
the trunk of the car right in front of
the house remember
and he goes hey thomas i'm gonna go on a
bike run to utah i'll be gone for three
days and in my head obviously you know
what i thought
open house for three days i'm getting
[ __ ] faced here i'm having people over
i'm getting [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah grandpa
and buddy reality goal oh okay grandpa
three days okay i just got work in
school i was going to college but
anybody out there that ever had a free
house that's what runs through your head
first like who
how many people do you think i can get
away with in here that's what i was
doing um
so
my grandpa leaves
my grandpa leaves i go to work i come
home he's still not there i'm like okay
damn he's on his bike right he'll be
back in three days
my friends come over i tell him yo we're
[ __ ] chilling tonight i
have six people or seven people not a
lot of people i don't [ __ ] with that
many people but i saw weed at the time
you guys have heard the story but if you
haven't uh next door to my grandpa's
house was the mexican family and their
daughter i was outside smoking weed one
time and she opened her window and was
like she was pretty she was cool as [ __ ]
and she was my friend shout out to jerry
i know you're married my bad shout out
to jerry she was cool as [ __ ]
and she's like oh i smoke weed to my
what [ __ ] hit this and normally i
would never be like it [ __ ] the [ __ ] i
don't know you but like yo you're my
neighbor
all right i [ __ ] with you you're my
neighbor if you're cool yeah hit this
you're my age like she was my age it was
she was tight she's not i remember she
sneaked out her window we'd smoke right
there across the fence in a makeshift
bottle or whatever
and it was cool she was my neighbor we'd
[ __ ] talk at night and [ __ ] and i go
back in the house it was she was very
cool she was chill
um
her mom [ __ ] despises me she thinks i
was banging her daughter
that's exactly and i never i never did i
was never that's not what my intentions
were she was just she was cool right she
was chilling you guys know what you guys
already know oh she can get pregnant get
away from me [ __ ] oh you're a woman
that can get pregnant get away from me
you guys know i my biggest fear was
having kids young that's why i didn't
date anybody until i met rosie because
she was cool as [ __ ]
that's the only reason everybody else
kind of like uh with like i always say
with jared with girls i'm jerry seinfeld
i'm like one little thing and go oh no i
can't deal with that for 30 years so i'm
like no no i just saw you litter i'm
[ __ ] done
little things i'm a [ __ ] anyway
her mom thinks i'm banging her i'm not
she's a [ __ ] her mom's [ __ ]
anyway i have all those people over and
the little back story is my neighbor
gets high with me sometimes her mom's
really cussed me out one time because
she went back in her room and she was
like what the [ __ ] you're high as hell
and i was still in the backyard so she
came outside was like yelling at me i'm
like what
you're smoking wait am i talking what
are you talking about i'm lying my ass
off what are you talking about i'm
smoking myself
i'm like your daughter i don't even see
her out here i was playing dumb i just
got high with a girl i just got [ __ ]
up with her anyway
i have all the friends over
and uh jerry comes over
her mom's not there and she gets so
violent i keep forgetting guys not
everybody smokes weed like me now
everybody smokes wee like marty smoking
right now like a [ __ ] maniac
not everybody rips it like that
okay
that was cloud that was a clown
not everybody does that
so i got jerry so [ __ ]
up guys
she was falling asleep on the couch
so we're all hanging out none of my
homies are like trying to hit her she's
the girl they know like y'all's my
neighbor full chill
um
she's cool she goes back home violently
red-eyed high stereotype high
[ __ ] up
violently high violently high that's my
favorite she needs to fall asleep like
right now because you're [ __ ] up
so me and my friends we get shitfaced
all my friends are over here's the
knight next door on the other side is mr
edwards mr edwards is from georgia i
believe he's about 85 old black dude
hey tom hey tommy spanish
mad southern i can almost understand
nothing he says but i love him mr
edwards is the [ __ ] coolest old man i
love that guy he's watched me grow up
since i was born he was there day one
he's been my neighbor my grandma and
grandpa's neighbor since like
1970-something he is [ __ ] awesome
so he and my grandpa water their lawn
every night at the same night same time
and talk over the fence you know on some
neighborly [ __ ] that's my grandpa and mr
edwards
by the way my grandpa looks like a black
dude too so
back then
they were the minorities on the block
talking
you know and now it's like oh yeah folks
there's a little more mexicans and [ __ ]
but hello more black people here
mercedes
it wasn't always hella mexican people so
they bought the houses when it was like
oh [ __ ] those mexican black people on
the block but my grandma's a jewish
woman so she's white as [ __ ]
it's a very weird mix of my family right
anyway so they're still talking 35 years
later 40 years later watering their
lawns and i know my grandpa i know he's
gonna be like hey well hey mr edwards
watch my grandson tonight i'm leaving
for three days make sure you don't have
a party but i already knew i already
know what he's gonna [ __ ] ask because
they got that bond their neighbors
they're cool when my grandpa passed away
ms edwards is [ __ ] heartbroken i
remember all this [ __ ] like it sucked
um
so
i have all my friends over and you know
jeebus my best friend
jebus
is the only one that slept there it's my
friend like he's gonna sleep there the
whole night everybody else you know we
get [ __ ] they leave
me and jeebus get [ __ ] shit-faced
to the max and they used to have this
little machine
it was like a a like a leaf blower but
this big and there's a bowl on top so
you light the bowl and it
blows it out so you can slide a bowl and
it goes
and it pumps weed smoke into your face
i had one
me and jesus are using it at my house
just like ah
letting it you know just nobody's there
nobody's there and i'm like yo there's a
certain song i want to listen to i was i
was three in the morning all [ __ ] up
my grandpa has an extensive
doo-wop and cd collection and um that's
what i grew up on was old-school [ __ ] so
i'm like there's a [ __ ] bobby heb
song i want to hear right now
[ __ ] up and i searched his entire
[ __ ] collection it was everywhere i
spread it across the whole living room
so i can find it because i was
shit-faced right
and me and jesus i found the song we're
playing it by the way i'm a baller i
went and got bed sheets and put them up
over the sides of the windows seals so
mr edwards couldn't peek in and see that
i had [ __ ] people there that's
right i did all that type of [ __ ] i had
fools coming through the side
parking down the street yeah i really
went above and beyond to make sure mr
edwards didn't catch me and when i went
outside to see where my friends was
because he said hey i'm here where's
that he was outside like on the middle
of our lawn in islam like looking in
like hey what's up mr hello how you
doing i'm good you just hang out my
friend jesus and just
close the door
and all right all right went back to
water islam like ah i knew it
and um
god i talked there's so much backstory
to [ __ ] we get [ __ ] up me and james we
get [ __ ] faced we go to the park across
the street and i'm so drunk i'm hitting
the [ __ ] thing and for some reason it
makes me throw her and i go genius this
thing's gonna give us cancer
i don't know why i said that like this
is plastic burning
and i just threw it into the field like
we got to get this away from us no more
and i was all drunk and i threw it and
the next morning i regretted it so
[ __ ] bad but i also was smoking of a
piece of plastic it probably shouldn't
have
and uh i said what i remember that night
me and she were on the couch and sleep
on the small couch i have to go to work
in the [ __ ] morning
okay i still have to go to work in the
morning
oh
sorry forgot to tell you guys
remember earlier in the day jerry jerry
came by got violently high forgot to say
her mom came over how did i forget her
mom came over about two hours later
and was just [ __ ] basically poking my
chest talking [ __ ] i know she was here
smoking weed she's [ __ ] up next door
her eyes are red as hell she can barely
talk to me she's falling asleep and in
my head i'm like yeah basically that's
fire but in person i'm like
i have no idea what you're talking about
i know you're 18. she's 17 years old i
know i'm going to call the cops i'm
going to talk to your grandfather i'm
like he's not a motorcycle ride you can
talk to him when he comes back
so i'm calling the cops go go ahead i'm
not even 18 years old i was lying i know
you're 18. i you know how i know you're
18 because you're out of high school i'm
like
[ __ ] i don't know what you're talking
about and then the grandma
behind her backing her up and i'm like
whoa all my friends are behind me in the
house just sitting down she looks past
me like yeah you have all these dudes
over here with my daughter and in my
head on my first stop [ __ ] nobody's
trying to bang your daughter over here
okay i told them all to leave her the
[ __ ] alone and you know i mean like i
was saying these things in my head
knowing the truth and i'm like all right
yeah talk to him it's great yeah it's
cool i have a good day i close it and
she [ __ ] hates she hates me and her
mom was kind of pretty too which kind of
made it like even worse like
ah i really i don't like you i don't
like you but uh it was a very weird
conflict with the neighbors when i got
home dirty look
like that and we're in merced small ass
[ __ ] six foot lawn we're right my
door on door with each other like oh
damn [ __ ] sub jerry
like that's how my relationship was for
my neighbor it sucked
it sucked anyway
i forgot she came over and then he went
the night happened me and james got
[ __ ] up cds all that stuff happened
boom where the little couch sleep wake
up at nine
i leave everything out because i'm like
[ __ ] dude i'll come home and clean i
go to work [ __ ] hung over bad
uh there's
you know we had a volcano too like a
volcano vaporizer so there was hella
weed that got vaped so it looks kind of
black so i left it all over the counter
top just dumping balls all night there's
beer cans there's a bong i didn't even
own a bong then it was a [ __ ] glass
bomb my friend mike logan logo [ __ ]
left at my house because he was over
there it was right there there was weed
stems on the [ __ ] countertops there
was [ __ ] joint roaches you know what
i mean like
i left in a [ __ ] mess
go to work
come back home
real quick here's my house here's the
park here's a street
there's the street pull up
sorry
90 degree angle but for all the way from
over here from like 400 yards away is
the park and this whole street you can
see my house so if you're in front of my
house you could see whoever's turning
from a huge long [ __ ] two blocks away
so i can see my house from the turn from
ramone's house so as i'm right here i
can see the house and i'm about halfway
down the block i'm just like oh my god
i'm so [ __ ] up oh my god
and i'm driving i'm already doing my
shift it's four o'clock i go from now i
go from 10 to four
so i drive and as i'm about a quarter
way to the stop sign and then when i
turn to the house
i look and my [ __ ] grandpa's sitting
right in the front
with two people and three motorcycles
this is not even [ __ ] 24 hours later
since he said i will be gone for three
days
i've never been caught by my grandpa
doing anything i've sold hundreds of
[ __ ] sacks out of this house never
been caught never been suspicious never
smelled never nothing
i'm pulling up to the stop sign and i
look and i'm like this
and the house is three houses in so it's
about what 70 yards i'm like or 60 yards
like that
oh my [ __ ] god
oh my god no way
oh my god no way i got all hot like
memory ferris bueller when cameron
accidentally kicks the car and it goes
all the way out that's how i felt like
what do i [ __ ] do
like the one time i have people over in
the one time or one time i have people
over the only thing i was thinking of
was like oh my god did i leave any wheat
out my drunk ass forgot about the cds i
forgot about the bong i forgot about the
vaped weed i forgot about the rope i
i'll get into that i come to the stop
sign and you know if i'm at the stop
sign i live three houses in there's they
can just look at me they know my car
drive it drive a dodge green intrepid
green dodge intrepid guys it's very
noticeable
i'm looking at him
and i go
just keep driving straight man don't
even go home that's what came into my
head like yo keep driving straight just
[ __ ] drive just move move away like
don't come back home like don't get i
couldn't bring it to myself because i'm
so cautious i couldn't i couldn't like
did you really get caught
did you really just get caught full
that's how i felt like you're a [ __ ]
idiot
i get halfway into the street and i'm
about to leave straight i go tom what
are you doing
so i make one of these turns
not a turn normally i went i'm gone i'm
leaving [ __ ] i didn't make enough [ __ ]
okay back
before i had to do a three-point turn
almost to the edge of like kirby and i
went oh my god it looked even more
like a [ __ ] idiot trying to
three-point turn a left-hand turn in the
street my grandma probably thinks i'm
still drunk [ __ ] i'm a driver for a
living
and
it's the slowest 60 yards i've ever
driven i took my foot off the gas and i
just rolled to the house
and i'm rolling up to the house
remember it's sidewalk in a six foot
yard the door it's a very small [ __ ]
house
three green lawn chairs
old guys steven seagal look at
[ __ ] i have never seen in my
life
my uncle robert just
that face
and my grandpa is late cross smoking
cigarette
sorry they were all smoking out smoke
just like that
i don't even look at him i
you know as a kid when you're trying to
get candy out of the machines the
quarter machine you turn it slow because
you heard at school when you turn it
slow you get more candy
you know what i'm talking about
[ __ ] that's how slow i turned my
key i went
i opened my door real slow
i grabbed
one thing at a time
just trying to just prolong this [ __ ]
whatever's about to happen
they're right here i have no tint
they're staring at me take my time like
this
they're this close
except i'm this way
[Laughter]
and i'm grabbing my stuff i get out the
car
you know when you close a door
you turn toward the car and close it i
did this one where i step out step left
and close it i'm just looking away from
them
like i'm looking away from my car just
going
and i walk around the car still not
looking again i'm around the trunk
and i get toward the lawn and then i go
what's up
that's all i say what's up
but like the look on me is like
people fall over those things the kids
punch and they go back
that's how i felt like
oh my [ __ ] god
what's up i get to the lawn i'm just
like that i'm four feet away from what's
up
and my grandpa goes
you have some fun last night huh
and i go oh yeah
sorry i took all your cds out
sorry i was looking for a cd i was going
to put him back but i was late to work i
was going to do it when i got home and
i'll go robert because
i have a little fun huh
[ __ ] the girl next door huh
and in my head i'm like
what
and my grandpa goes
hey guy
and hey guy means
hey good job a dj banger oh that's
awesome good for [ __ ] you i'll i'll
leave more often all of that was in this
hey guy
uncle robert goes yeah the mom came by
and said
she was over here last night and you
know house kind of a mess you guys are
partying
and i go oh my god they think you had
just the girl over here getting [ __ ]
up and banging the [ __ ] neighbor when
you were gone and that's why there's
weed and cds and drink everywhere and i
go [ __ ] run with it run with it and
go
oh yeah
the girl next door and he goes all right
just man matt clean up next time man
that's what my grandpa and uncle robbie
just made make sure you clean up next
time you know it's all good i go
all right sorry man
sorry grandpa i'll clean up right now
and they're just
they birch they [ __ ] telepathically
went
yeah
that's what they did that's my [ __ ]
grandson like you see the girl next door
that's what they were saying and i was
like
was your was he all crazy about weed
like your mom was or not so much to
begin with i've never talked to my
grandpa about weed he's never brought up
with me i've never been caught i've
never shown him anything but super
[ __ ] respectfulness yeah but if he
were to have seen it wouldn't have had a
full meltdown one time there was a stem
on the couch
and i know there was a stem on the couch
because there was a fat one and i
remember thinking did i forget to move
it because i was rolling a blunt there
when he was gone one time and i came
home and i'm like oh my god is he
sitting on a stem
because i had just left to the store i
came back and i went to the bathroom
came back and the stem was on his
armchair coffee table like he had found
it
hey that's yours huh
and he left it right there and i came
back in and was like oh my god i'm
saying they're talking to him like yeah
blah blah and i'm like oh my god and
he's watching my grandpa isn't that
crazy i'm like whoa do you see that
other movie and i grabbed the stem from
him and i put in my pocket and i know he
knew i did it so it was unspoken but the
thing is i've heard of my grandpa's
stories of him getting shit-faced oh all
right my grandpa used to be my grandpa
has eight dui's bro mm-hmm before they
did the three guys getting strike i got
about eight duis yeah this is from the
70s and up all right and he also i've
heard he's passed out highest [ __ ]
many parties my grandparents have a huge
afro and they used to throw popcorn in
his hair when he passed out because my
grandpa was known to pass out off weed
so i've heard my grandpa smoke weed with
my mom's friends before too i've heard
these stories and my grandpa drinks
so no i don't think we got mad but i
never wanted to be like i'm in your
house i'm [ __ ] getting high here i
never wanted that
uh-huh but homer how about this one time
my sister left the bong outside my
grandpa [ __ ] picked it up and she
went out and said oh my god grandpa was
like it's okay it's hot out here and he
handed it to her all right so he's fine
my grandpa's cool he's born in l.a in
the [ __ ] 50s yeah okay he's chilling
but
i'm not trying to just like just his ass
sorry
hey guy fist bump [ __ ] and i'm like
i walk in bro there is so much stuff
everywhere i look at the floor like it's
not just oh my god the bomb and i look
around the [ __ ] we ground up the
roaches and i just start scooping
everything up they come they give me
like three minutes and they come in and
i clean up the whole [ __ ] house i was
just scrambling just throwing [ __ ] into
[ __ ] trash just
i remember thinking i hope you didn't
walk through the whole [ __ ] house yet
because it didn't look like they had
walked in look at the open door went
yeah grandpa
[ __ ] everywhere in here that's
basically what he wanted he's like
wow man
it's a mess in there
and the girl saw my grandpa roll up and
went hey hey your [ __ ] grandson
that's what happened she [ __ ] was
like oh you're out of town for three
days huh huh and she went over there and
was like yo you're [ __ ] grandkid yeah
keep away from my [ __ ] daughter
and my grandpa just went oh my god i'm
sorry i'm sorry but in his head all
right
you know what i'm like he was he firing
a fred durst keep on rolling baby that's
how he that's how he imagined him
backward red hat
um
cleaned up the entire area
and then my grandpa went on his ride he
only came home because they were
picking up their friend near this area
and he's like i'm gonna go home and grab
some more [ __ ] just in case i need it
only reason he came back oh sure he
didn't go to utah he went up north to
santa cruz area to get my uncle robert
chilled there for the night came back
down to pick up their friend's drive to
utah
my [ __ ] luck
that was his test though i was like you
know what i'm gonna show up tomorrow see
what happened he was right
he was right but he didn't know i
[ __ ] just chill with a bunch of dudes
all right and got [ __ ] faced and
listened to a bunch of cds at night that
was fun
but uh that's the time i just you know
what i'm gonna let him think whatever he
wants to think yeah and i'm just gonna
get out of the situation that's a funny
clip so you ever see cut back to you
throwing the [ __ ] plastic bong under
the grass and [ __ ] yeah dude that that
would be just
with jesus all [ __ ] shipping what
song do you want to listen to man
that was us this is
this is when e-bombs world was popping
more than youtube so we're watching
ebon's world clips and [ __ ]
[Music]
but yeah i just let it be guys and
that's the first party and only party i
ever threw at anyone's house like that i
never brought people over like that
anywhere it's terrifying that was the
first party i ever did and i got caught
and one of the only times i was ever
caught for anything
except
banging the neighbor
who you legitimately weren't trying you
were trying to not bang her
i don't want to get no girl pregnant
aren't you getting no i'm good
i'm good
i won't say later on we weren't chilling
and talking and hanging out after we
were both in college together
that was different we were we there was
another story
but
she was very awesome and she's super
[ __ ] cool
and uh
that was my first party shout out to
jerry for getting me off the
[ __ ] hook
uh
so my grandpa went to the grave thinking
that nothing ever happens and her mom
thought she was going to get you in the
most trouble but got you out of trouble
that's amazing
she really thought she got my
little does she know my grandpa's a
[ __ ] hooligan
he doesn't give a [ __ ]
that was it my first party and that is
the first story time of season two
oh if this wasn't painted so i was about
to punch a hole this wall that's how
excited that [ __ ] got me right now
that was perfectly timed
explosion
oh yeah what time we got 204 13. [ __ ]
that's fine doesn't say to 12.
oh well we did good we did good season
season one was great
super fun we learned from our mistakes
we know better to
hey
let's film at 10 o'clock at night so
it's not 104 in here
all right guys i don't care how hot it
is outside it's
bomb in here it's [ __ ] 5 45 right now
is it it's amazing
i'm gonna get back it's gonna be a
normal time
all right hell yeah get this thing out
of there tomorrow
then you're going to the [ __ ] to
tennessee yeah
okay
well josh is coming here so you guys
josh is coming here so i'll be hanging
out with josh i got a little piece of
tennessee over here
um guys i don't even i can't even talk
about any guests because
let's wait till they're here
i'm not gonna start telling you guys
about any guests
if we do ever mention booking a guest
just know booking guests is not easy and
people's schedules are crazy so yes just
because
yeah so people say they want to come on
they eventually will yeah so we'll get
it done all right i promise but until
then it's just me you and marty
and the garage or room that you're in
hanging out with your friends or alone
and either way
[ __ ] awesome
super sick thank you guys thank you guys
for being here the entire season
uh
just like names off the top of my head
that evoking
maddie b
i think it's maddie severins i see these
names pop up alt raccoon crab i see
pop-up and non-stop zachary hill i see
all these names
not i'm not leaving you guys out on
purpose i'm just trying to say some
names are off the top of my head
thank you guys demon dreams i think it
is too
guys thank you guys every episode
[ __ ] they're in every [ __ ] premiere
oh shout out to mom shout out to my mom
every [ __ ] episode
every episode thank you very much guys
uh vic woods 420 i believe backwood is
in there he has a car on his profile pic
if i remember correctly
guys thank you guys
for real hell yeah sick it's the only
way we're able to keep it going yeah
thank you guys marty and i
season two
this is where it's like oh
now we're ready yeah we both just got
fired up i didn't realize we weren't
actually [ __ ] fired up every time i
thought we were i thought we were like
until we got in here it felt different
yeah
are you [ __ ] serious
that's how i feel like
hulkamania
like i'm about to stand up that's how i
feel hulkamania has just started oh yeah
okay the undertaker just did this
[ __ ]
that's us right now i'm excited as [ __ ]
let's go
all right let's go it's demolition man
and i just got frozen right now so it's
the very beginning
well i'm not gonna i'm gonna
i'm just gonna stop with this with the
references because it'll never
[ __ ] stop
all right i'm i'm [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
schwarzenegger i'm badass naked in a
circle this is the beginning of
terminator 2.
i'm just going to stop i'm going to go
through 400 movies right now i'm dave
chappelle i'm walking through a hospital
with a [ __ ] mom
excuse me
or the master of the custodial arts
uh god these references just go away
sorry
guys marty anything to say
i just feel amazing just my usual thank
you guys i appreciate all the love on
all fronts really fires us up i'm
feeling great
fresh new chapter in life what are the
odds building a house and a set at the
same time the way things are all just
driving together i'm looking forward to
just getting back into a new routine and
growing the show
when we started the show i had a full
roster of [ __ ] clients occupying my
whole life and since i mean even just in
our first season it's really doing a
dwindle down to the point that this is
almost my
only focus so
that's really you know really the goal i
feel great about it man i'm ready to
just [ __ ]
push forward just do all kinds of cool
[ __ ] through the show
i'm excited keep doing it real [ __ ]
big [ __ ]
[Music]
that's supposed to be the explosion but
it worked
that's me every time i don't know about
you guys i'm doing this [ __ ] every time
we start this one computer yeah i know
why every time i feel that way a hot 16
is going to come out one of these times
i can tell
that's a wrap that's a rap reference
sometimes you know that right
not an r kelly reference oh [ __ ] oh god
oh damn this [ __ ] is working
today
that's just on it
i took all the brains this morning
probiotics ate a yogurt
that's right that's why
that's why we're not getting recommended
so i'm going to piss on you drip drip
drip gonna peel welcome to this bite
take me to this special place close your
eyes show me your face
cause i'm gonna piss on it
i know the whole song he's having a cd
uncle john
in his black cheap cherokee
bumping drip drip drip drip drip
on you
haters wanna hate
all right we gotta stop
i don't even want
none of the above i want to piss on you
we gotta stop piss on you i'll pee on
you i'll piss on you
i'll be on stage singing that [ __ ] one
day
and they're supposed to do this
all right i'm going damn why are you
looking up at me man i'm chucking not
taller than you and that's what i'm
going to say to him
yep
marty
[Laughter]
that's wholesome look out of here
all right guys this is season [ __ ]
two
episode one i don't know what the title
this [ __ ] is but thank you guys so much
for being here we talked about robin
williams and people [ __ ]
saying hateful things and
51st day rapes all that stuff good [ __ ]
and that's not even a topic and we
talked about 50 first dates
ridiculous
okay oh we all that was from dementia
oh our show yeah not for real we'll
spiral into something it's not for
everybody
for sure
[ __ ] what a dick i can't believe i just
i did that okay i forgot guys thank you
so much for watching thank you for
helping us out thank you for supporting
the sponsors thank you for [ __ ]
everything for being here eight million
[ __ ] times all right 36 episodes guys
thank you so much for watching this has
been
episode one of season two
one of 50 or 52. this is the dope as
usual podcast we are here to talk about
life drugs problems accomplishments and
everything in between i [ __ ] that up
damn it i always do it's life drugs
problems accomplishments and everything
in between
you got it i got it yeah i got it i got
it uh so guys thank you today with a
whole lot of drugs a whole lot of life a
whole lot of problems and
accomplishments
also some in between
you know what's weird i'm i all i
imagined was drinking a mandarin [ __ ]
burritos [ __ ] soda right now that was
so weird some things are delicious
though [ __ ] man i just [ __ ] chugged
it in my mind right now as i looked in
the camera got all disoriented that
shit's addicting i haven't drank one in
[ __ ] four years flashback like when
people catch a late acid tripper that's
exactly you're back popping the ecstasy
[ __ ] sparked again that's what
happened to me right now except i
thought of
sweating in the sun drinking the [ __ ]
soap yola loves orange soda yeah i do i
do i do
and that's where we wouldn't be complete
without a keenan encoder goddamn show
that's we're gonna leave off on this
color looks just like orange soda guys
thank you so much
uh
thank you all right before you get out
here drop a like if you're in the live
chat [ __ ] thank you
this has been another episode very first
new season new set new [ __ ] equipment
new everything thank you guys from marty
drastic graphics and i have a dope s day
yup
up i hope that guy's done tinting the
windows i can't wait to see it
i'm [ __ ] higher than usual
that's the name now higher than usual
i love it
do you want to hit this joint
do you want to hit this joint that is a
good
title oh higher than usual i love that
[Music]
perfect
[Music]